okay it's uh
just past 12 30. i see we have three
subcommittee members here so we can go
we do have a quorum
and uh my name is doug thomas i'm the
chair of the subcommittee for the
hb 1644
we now have four subcommittee members
here
that's okay
but we do have a time constraint so we
we have to continue
we had a subcommittee meeting
last week we had
additional
information that they were exchanged
and the main and since we went so long
last week we
reserved a very short time today
basically for our subcommittee to take a
vote on the recommendation to our our
full committee
however we do have
my understanding is that we have two
speakers here or will have
that came here especially i know they'll
be testifying during the public hearing
schedule for one o'clock but i will give
them the courtesy to come here and speak
for no more than five minutes
on perhaps something that they may want
to expand upon when they go to public
hearing
so
if you
in order to facilitate this if i have a
pink card i guess so i just have their
name
and where they're from whoever is going
to be speaking during the public hearing
um is and i don't know their name i'm
sorry uh
simon do you have a
name
sure
uh
and then let me just look at it and then
i will give to nick hang on
is that swanson okay give it to nick
that's for the public that's for the
subcommittee
records nick
so if mr swanson uh would like to come
up and address the subcommittee please
do you have five minutes
i'll test this first am i
okay with you you hit the closer a
little bit closer how's that sound yeah
you can pull the mic closer to you too
sorry about the noise can you just say
your name on who you represent um my
name is eric swanson i've been asked by
ctia to come and talk to you today
so uh good afternoon mr chair and
members of the subcommittee
i've been asked to talk to you about
health and safety aspects of 5g
technology
first a few words about myself i'm a
physicist at the university of
pittsburgh
i'm a fellow of the american physical
society and i'm a member of the union of
concerned scientists
the opinion that i'm going to tell you
today is a consensus view
of of the scientific
view of the safety of 5g technology
as you know 5g and cell phones work with
electromagnetic waves
these waves are sometimes also called
radiation which i want to stress is not
nuclear radiation
the waves in total
in totality are called the spectrum
some parts of the spectrum are actually
dangerous that's in the high frequency
or high energy
end of the electromagnetic spectrum and
you're familiar with some of this x-rays
for instance are electromagnetic waves
they're high energy and
you don't want to expose yourself to
x-rays too much that's why the
technician leaves the room when you get
your your teeth x-rayed things like that
if you go up to even higher frequencies
you get to things like gamma rays which
are very rare in nature but they can
outright kill you
unlike in the in the movies
if you go to lower frequencies you get
to things like ultraviolet radiation so
ultraviolet forms part of the natural
light that's emitted by the sun
and you are well aware that if you spend
too long out in the sun you'll tan your
skin responds to this energetic incoming
waves
by tanning and if you stay out too long
you might put yourself at risk of skin
cancer
now things change dramatically just
below frequency just below the frequency
of ultraviolet radiation um that's where
visible light comes in so it's exactly
the light in
in this room
visible light is below what's called the
ionization threshold
this is a is like a step function things
change dramatically once you go from uv
radiation to visible light and below
now this non-ionizing radiation is does
not cause things like skin cancer it
acts completely differently when it
comes in contact with tissue and you're
actually aware of this at an intuitive
level already
you know that you can spend all day
inside underneath these lights
you're not going to get tan
you're certainly not going to get skin
cancer it doesn't matter how long you
stay underneath these lights
the reason is that the frequency and the
energy emitted by these lights is below
the ionization threshold
by the way this this was first
understood in 1905 by good old albert
einstein he's the one who first
explained the list
so the technology that we're talking
about
5g
is higher in frequency than the older
technology 4g but it is still a factor
of 30 000 below this threshold
and i stress again that it's a threshold
so even if you were a factor of two
below the threshold it would still be
perfectly safe
now this radiation doesn't do nothing
it does have an effect on materials the
primary fact is that it moves things
around it moves molecules moves
electrons around and that slow motion is
well known to us as heat
so if for example you were to step out
into the sun
you would feel heat on your skin and
it's this is exactly the effect that
we're talking about
in fact the fcc could regulate the sun
if it chose to it operates at a much
higher frequency than 5g technology
and it's far it violates fcc regulations
by the way the sun would have to be
outlawed
by about a factor of 16.
so the fcc regulates this because we
can't see it and so
we can't our eyes don't detect radio
waves so they regulate it for us the
idea is that people shouldn't be exposed
to too much of a heating effect
so what they do they don't conduct
experiments that's something of a myth
they consult with national bodies and
international bodies thousands of
experiments get examined they are
continually reviewing experiments as
they come up they recently completed a
review of new technology of about 200
studies just in the past few months
what they do is they set limits
about a factor of 50 below anything
that's remotely detectable in these
experiments
now i can tell you what these limits are
but
it's just a number so what i'd rather do
is illustrate what these limits are
so to do that i want to talk about my
brain for a minute
so my brain
uses about 15 percent of the energy that
my body
consumes every day it's about 2 000
calories a day that actually works out
to 100 watts
so you know
a human is is very much in terms of
energy like an old-fashioned
incandescent light bulb
15 of that is 15 watts my brain weighs
about 2 pounds something like that and
what that means is that my brain
is operating at a a power rating of 15
watts per kilogram
now
because it's warm it's at room
temperature right now that molecules in
my brain are jiggling around and when
they jiggle around they actually emit
electromagnetic radiation
it's not 5g and it's not visible it's in
between it's called infrared radiation
or thermal radiation you've probably
seen it on you know james bond movies or
things like this when they're using
response and you have like one minute
please sum up thank you
um and that means that my brain and all
of our brains are thermal radio
transmitters
they violate the fcc regulations if the
fcc chose to regulate brains by about a
factor of 10.
so the message i'm trying to get across
to you is that these regulations are
extremely strict they are very safe
to summarize
although the the technology of 5g is new
the physics of 5g is the same as it's
always been as 4g and 3g and 2g and the
biology is the same
and the fcc
regulates this technology completely
adequately there's nothing to fear from
it
thank you for your attention i'm
happy to answer questions of course um
thank you mr swanson uh
if anyone feels the need to answer a
question on the subcommittee we can or
we will be having a public hearing in a
few minutes where mr swanson will have
an opportunity to go into more detail
so that being said thank you for your
time here swanson and is there one more
person we have time for one more speaker
could you bring the pink card over to me
so i know your name and i'll give it to
our subcommittee clerk
representative white
mr hancock is it yes okay welcome mr
hancock
you are representing yourself it says
here
and so go ahead you have five
building the minutes
for them in
uh canada i worked with secret service
with microwave transmissions across
the northern border of the united states
and i helped design a lot of the systems
that are used
today
this bill came to my attention because
of rep naughtier
and
i was quite honestly shocked at the
misinformation
sorry there we go um excuse me um i hate
to interrupt you i was under the
impression that the other speaker we had
here was
is this your speaker represented
daughter oh i'm sorry okay go ahead
so
so first of all 5g is an encoding
standard uh it's being used by everybody
as a marketing standard but it's an
encoding standard and it's only a slight
modification improvement on 4g in fact
it's basically where 4g ended up and
they just renamed it and made a new
standard for it
the key
and i think the sole
concern with this
board here is that
frequency
i.e how fast the wave moves
and how much power that wave has
but as i just heard
the handset
actually produces more radiation at the
head than the towers do
and frequencies that are used by
cellular service are about to be put
into use in cellular service and in fact
the amount of radiation produced by
these cell phone towers and even your
handset is orders of magnitude less than
what came before so as an example
t-mobile has 5g throughout the state of
new hampshire already
at t verizon also do well in case of
t-mobile they're their cell phone
service for 5g is almost exclusively in
television channels that less than five
years ago we're broadcasting at 50 000
watts in this state right now there was
i live in the keene area there was two
towers that had to be reassigned and
reallocated and new transmitters put up
both of those were over 25 000 watts
to be replaced by cell phone towers that
broadcast at
100 watts
in the same frequency
so as a result of this technology
not only has it gotten safer
not only do we have more technology in
the state have more communication and
more opportunity as a result of this
technology coming into play
we actually are producing less radiation
and as is noted in multiple testimonies
that i've seen
it's called the inverse square law
so for every meter you go from a tower
the power drops off
and power is directly equatable to how
deep
the wave will penetrate the skin
so as a result
if you've got 50 000 watts and you have
100 watts and they're roughly the same
place because yes a lot of the cell
phone towers are actually on radio
towers and television towers
on exactly the same frequency the cell
phone tower is vastly safer for
everybody involved
if we go and look at the new frequencies
like c-band that everybody's concerned
about because of
bad airplanes that were designed poorly
and have poor insulation
the interference is because they didn't
insulate anything but those same
frequencies were broadcasting at 50 to
190 000 watts
off of satellites that you can see today
the remnants of what it used to be used
for because of all the six foot dishes
that are still left in people's yards
but those were broadcasting at thousands
of times more power than the cell phone
towers are
okay even millimeter wave today
right now as we speak
there's 250 000 watts
of milling down
simply to tell us that there's a snow
storm coming
because the same frequencies that
they're talking about using for
millimeter wave of which there's no
implementation in new hampshire and very
little reason to believe that it will be
widespread because of the
characteristics of it
it's everywhere starlink satellite that
if you were to pass this legislation
would be absolutely subject to this
it's in exactly the millimeter wave
frequencies and you're going to cut off
high-speed internet access to the vast
majority of the state as a result
because there's no other feasible way to
provide broadband to all of coast county
as an example mr hancock assuming you
have one minute to summarize please so
as a result
exactly like what happened with the epa
when they passed legislation to control
nuclear reactors and fuel refineries and
the consequence of their good intentions
they consequently
is is that because of the regulations
they passed we actually
pollute vastly more now
in the united states than any other
country in the world because of those
very legislations because those reactors
those refineries have not been upgraded
the same pathway has occurred and will
continue to occur when it comes to
electromagnetic frequencies because if
you block this you're blocking new
towers new developments lower power
better frequencies closer signals that
are of lower power and don't need to
broadcast so strongly as a result of
this so all that will remain is the old
legacy technology
thank you so much for your testimony i
will remind everyone that
there will be time at the public hearing
to speak a little more in depth on this
again
i only allowed these two speakers out of
courtesy because they traveled some
distance to get here today
and uh
one o'clock
at this point i just want to say that
the
subcommittee
in some talking feels that we've heard
testimony pretty strongly on both sides
of the fence
and it's very complex unfortunately this
is an early bill
we would have liked to have been able to
put together an amendment to make it
more palpable that's something that
could have been used
but time won't
allow us
i believe
because of this and because we believe
that there is something out there
we do understand there are some medical
issues
with the public
that cannot be denied
we also believe that there's heavy
scientific evidence that would point to
the contrary to causation
but we do realize that there might be
some correlation out there we just
really we we can't we just don't have
enough time to figure out what we should
do about it
so i believe uh the subcommittee
is in a position to
make a motion of recommendation
to the full committee and although i
haven't assigned anyone that yet uh
representative white
would you make a motion i i believe
interim study uh would be the best
course of action
are you willing to make a motion to that
uh
i will i i just want to say that i've
struggled a lot personally with this
i've gone back and forth on this i have
not had the time i've only got about
halfway through the 400 page commission
report and i think one study
which there's thousands out there to
look at um
but yes i'll entertain that motion to
move this to interim study uh
noting that i have i have concerns about
this
motion has been made for interim study
as a second
representative partial
second
any discussion on the motion for interim
study
yes i represent mark partial
yes before us we have an amendment to
the original bill
um
it does define more clearly what we do
mean by antenna i understand there's
still concerns about that
um
and also removes the registry uh as
being
well that could be problematic at this
time so we just wanted to focus on the
actual placement of the towers
there is concern from him radio
operators which may
dictate the deep necessity for a further
amendment i think it's something worth
talking about i think it's definitely
worth keeping this bill alive there are
a lot of questions around this
and
i
would prefer seeing this an otp a bill
because in effect that will put a
moratorium on the deployment of these
towers until we can more fully
understand the
repercussions of what we may be doing
uh without that moratorium i think that
uh it's a given a green light to the
industry when
there's a lot of
questions remaining unanswered
um
i love the idea of an interim study i
think this is an important issue i think
a lot of homework has been done already
and i hope we can actually
uh
oh what's the word uh vote to uh
vote against the uh
interim study though at this time and
give this an otpa so that we can buy the
time to actually study this free from
having it deployed
okay my understanding is that you've
taken into the motion for interim study
for the subcommittee can i not do that
then maybe i better do that i'm very
sorry
uh a matter of convenience
representative lauder i'll second the
motion to interim study okay vote's been
seconded for uh interim study i'm i may
remind the study committee that the
subject of the uh
amendment and
representative comments can certainly be
made during the uh public hearing uh and
also when we go to executive session
when we actually do vote on interim
study those comments can meet at that
time and
and your comments can be duly noted uh
so with with that being said thank you
for your education sure uh and seeing
that there are uh four members of our
committee here uh mr clerk mr
representative white would you call
the vote for uh those in favor of of
interim study for the subcommittee
recommendation to the full committee
yes so what do i i'm just calling the
vote call the roll call okay uh
representative thomas
i'm last oh you're last my
representative notter
yes
representative white yes
representative partial you're saying all
no and representative callie pitts is
not here correct
okay so me and representative thomas yes
so apparently a vote of three to one the
subcommittee is recommending interim
study to the full committee which will
be presented at the executive session
later on this afternoon
with that being said
i have no further comments i'm going to
adjourn the subcommittee and prepare for
the public hearing for 1644 with
chairman votes thank you and thank you
all for coming here welcome to heavy
comments at 1 o'clock
i would like to call to order
this session of the house science
technology and energy committee
i request that everybody take your seat
before we open the public hearing the
resumption of the public hearing on
house bill 1644.
i'd ask you all to rise and join
representative lex berezni as he leads
us in the pledge of allegiance
johnson
okay good afternoon everybody i would
like to now
resume the public hearing on house bill
which was recessed
two weeks ago
i'm going to be
holding this
resumed committee meeting public hearing
until 1 59 pm
at 2 o'clock this committee is scheduled
to go into executive session on five
early bills
so far i have five pink cards of people
who would like to testify at this
resumed public hearing
if there are any persons in the room who
wanted to testify on this bill
but have not submitted a pink card you
must do so
in order to to testify
because we have five pink cards now and
may get more later i'm going to restrict
everybody who testifies to five minutes
of actual testimony followed by whatever
questions the committee might seek to
seek to ask
we're going to try to keep each person
down to
a total of 10 minutes so that we can get
through all this
so at that i will call on the first
person to testify for us today and that
is mark
doyle of the department of safety
mr doyle
good afternoon mr chairman members of
the committee i want to take opportunity
to thank you for having me speak today
and specif speak specifically to the
public safety perspective of the impact
of this bill you won't be hearing from
me
relative to any of the science or the
impact on the business and industry
association but i think it's prudent
that you folks hear from
the public safety perspective of what
kind of impact the passage of this bill
will have
currently as written this bill would
jeopardize our ability to provide
emergency communications for the
department of safety and our statewide
public safety partners in the community
that they serve
as it would adversely affect
antenna placement for radio
communications specifically for our
statewide public safety first responders
who rely on and depend upon robust
reliable and redundant communications
capabilities
this would adversely infect new
construction designed to enhance
coverage throughout the state to include
land mobile radio or lmr and lte and
cellular network technologies and
networks it would also adversely impact
impact the future capabilities to
include leveraging the integration of
land mobile radio with cellular and lte
technologies for example push-to-talk
integration as well as land mobile radio
over the lte network these are all
capabilities that currently exist and
that are being used around the state
it would also impact and
adversely impact the fulfillment of the
governor's task force on school safety
recommendation that our division has
been charged with at the division of
emergency services and communications as
the director i'm directly responsible
for overseeing the implementation of
those recommendations that have been put
forth
by the director of homeland security and
emergency management and compiled for
the governor to review and approve that
recommendation specifically speaks to
enhancing radio or cellular coverage for
emergency communications
including the placement of cell boosters
and antennas in and around and on top of
schools near school buildings to enhance
the response from an emergency first
responder perspective
we've also explored many opportunities
with regards to to leveraging available
technologies to enhance public safety
communications throughout this state be
it existing lmr networks public safety
communications
or the current future capabilities of
technology such as firstnet
this bill will constrain our ability to
have reliable and interoperable
communications for our first responders
especially during an integrated disaster
response
currently a t firstnet is on a current
schedule for build out in the state of
new hampshire and are planning for the
next five years of expansion which
includes antenna placement on existing
and newly constructed towers for the
national public safety broadband network
which is nationwide this technology
currently and
intends to continue to provide
prioritized voice and data traffic for
our first responder community in times
of disaster or recovery
as well as a number of integrated
emergency management first responder
applications available only to firstnet
subscribers
there are approximately right now in
this state about 200 agencies statewide
on that firstnet platform now with
thousands of individual firstnet
subscribers all reliant upon the
capabilities and interoperability that
firstnet provides
more of which will continue to enhance
and grow our ability to cont to continue
to provide and provision emergency
communications across the state to our
first responder partners this is also
going to potentially affect our ability
to have calls provisioned to the 9-1-1
call center as we oversee the 9-1-1
system in the state because about right
now 80 percent of our call volume in the
911 center is from existing cellular
networks and cellular service
subscribers
about nine percent is based on landline
and that landline number continues to
drop while the number of cellular
subscribers and cellular call traffic to
the 911 center continues to increase
because of the topography associated
with the state of new hampshire most of
you know it's not a flat state we rely
explicitly especially when it comes to
wilderness response and for some of
those
less than
better served areas of the state where
cellular or broadband connectivity
exists we rely on the cellular networks
for folks to be able to reach out to us
to get the help that they need when they
need it so that the mission of the 911
center is accomplished to locate
communicate and connect people in an
emergency with the help that they need
by whatever technologies exist 30
seconds please
that pretty much wraps up what i had to
plan to speak to you relative to the
impact that this bill potentially would
have on our first responder community as
well as our ability to continue to
provide and leverage emergency
communications thank you mr chair thank
you mr doyle i expect that you'll
entertain questions i certainly will the
chair recognizes representative thomas
for a question
thank you mr chair thank you for taking
my question am i to understand that uh
your comments involving the spill
are they related to the
ambiguous wording referencing
towers in general
and and whatnot or are your comments
directly related to
whatever technology would be prevented
for proceeding to 5g capability
thank you for your question and it's i
think it's a little bit of both it's
ambiguous to the degree that nobody's
really nailed down what the term
telecommunications
antenna mean it could
broadly be defined as radio
communications as well the technologies
that you speak to are important to kind
of consider as well because we're using
and i say we collectively at the
department of safety as well as the
first responders that are in your
communities right now are using a number
of technologies that include lte
coverage but also include the ability to
integrate lte and the radio
communication systems that they
currently use so that when we have gaps
in coverage in and around the state
we all know that radio isn't a perfect
solution and we all know that lte is in
a perfect solution when it comes to
communications because there are dead
spots
however when your ability exists and we
currently have that ability right now
and it's being used in some sections of
the state to integrate the two it
broadly covers a large swath of areas
that wouldn't otherwise be served in
those underserved areas so to your point
this bill would impact their ability to
continue to use those resources and
expand upon them if in fact it went and
passed follow-up follow-up
uh thank you mr chairman thanks for the
follow-up so in other words
if we were to if we were to just keep
the waiters right now that is using uh
what would be considered 4g technology
for lack of a better term
that there would
be gaps in the system that the 5g
technology would be able to fill
no i can't speak too too much
to
what the coverage disparity if there is
between what the 4g cellular network
provides and what the 5g cellular
network can provide i can't speak to
this though
that
the 5g network as i understand it
is used as
a technology to augment the ability to
provision a lot of data across the
cellular network we're using a lot of
voice but what first responders are
looking for right now is the ability to
get that data to them in the field the
5g signal as i understand it is able to
provision that data far more
expeditiously and far more efficiently
so that the first responders of the
community can get that versus the 4g
network that's currently out there thank
you
thank you uh representative plett is
recognized for a question
yes you had written testimony you were
reading from i captured one tenth of
what you said could you submit that
please i have i've provided to
representative notter thank you
okay thank you
further questions for mr doyle
representative mcgee is recognized for a
question
thank you mr chairman and thank you mr
doyle for taking my question
i was making notes as you were speaking
and you mentioned 200 agencies um
that are currently working with the
first
and thousands of um first net
subscribers
so
uh i'm assuming your references to first
responders
is is that what you're talking about
there
thank you for your question let me
clarify when we talk about firstnet
firstnet is part of
the national public safety broadband
network initiative that was put forth
several years ago that every state has
opted in to use and when we talk about
the national public safety broadband
network it is exactly what that is
defined as it's a broadband network
that's designed specifically for public
safety and first responders to use in
times of crisis long story short it came
as a result of the nine
uh 911
commission that
in
investigated what went wrong with a
multi-agency integrated response to a
disaster and the interoperability issues
and the log gm associated with
communications networks during the
course of that response
again long story short they've come a
long way to recommend that what should
be in place is a dedicated
pipeline
of communications availability of first
responders so that when the networks get
clogged that pipeline will continue to
exist when they decided that that was
going to happen the fcc awarded the
firstnet
project to att at t has that across the
country for all 50 states and the
territories that are on board with the
firstnet platform what they're designed
and been charged to do is over the next
few years in five-year increments is
work within the states and they're
working with our division to make sure
that the the scaling out
of that program and that project done in
such a way that it's going to meet
certain metrics that att has been had
their feet held to by uh the fcc when it
comes to the for that project now they
don't do it unilaterally they make this
decision based upon
coverage they based upon
geogeography they base it upon
population the number of first
responders in a particular state what
they've done with new hampshire though
is work very closely with the statewide
interoperability executive committee
in the state to identify where those
gaps exist so that first responders in
and around the state not just in the
rural areas and not just in the urban
areas have the ability to leverage
that communications platform that's been
going on for the better part of the last
five years and they're right now in the
second phase of that the plan for the
following five years which includes
building out on existing towers as well
as identifying areas within the state
that need that coverage because the
first responders have asked for it in
those areas that are currently
underserved
thank you before i recommend
the member for a follow-up could i ask
that you
make your answers as succinct as
possible we have a limited amount of
time follow-up representative mcgee
thank you so much
the other question i had is we've
received some notes from ham radio
operators and you mentioned radio
um i i don't really understand how that
is affected by this and i i i mean i
know what i read from what people ask
but i guess i would ask you
how you view that
they spoke to us in terms of the
security they might provide
uh in an in an event where something
went wrong they think that that's part
of their charge is having this extra
communication uh level
and i don't know a lot about that world
so i just wonder how that feeds into
this thank you for your question and
i'll try to constrain in such a way that
i'm staying within the timelines but
the ham radio amateur radio operators in
this state like they are in many other
states are partnering closely with
public safety and in new hampshire they
are part of what we call the emergency
services function esf ii when the state
emergency operations center is open in
the event that we need to utilize their
services because sometimes you may have
to have them come on board we've used
them during certain exercises to
leverage the ability for them to be able
to communicate on a different radio
network altogether and it may impact
them to based upon how the wording is is
defined whether they can erect or
construct new construction when it comes
to putting up their own antennas around
the state okay thank you representative
samsich is recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you mr doyle
um
i i understand from what you're saying
your concerns about
the lack of opportunities that may be
closed off by this bill
uh to some of the services
however right now you're already
providing these services without 5g so
it's not like
all these services couldn't happen
unless 5g is there
and this bill is focusing on some of the
claimed negative effects of 5g so a lot
of the people in new hampshire have some
concerns and worries
and it seems to me
we should take those seriously
uh so
there's always a way working around
technology to give you the same result
as another question please yes so
so are you are are you
would you share the concerns that people
might have to know that before you
implement technology like this they need
to know that it's safe for them
i can speak to
when you spoke about 5g technology and
again i want to make sure that the
conversation i'm having with you is
framed in such a way that it's not
science specific that i've heard a lot
of testimony about the science and how
5g
will or will not impact an individual or
affect an individual per se however i
can tell you this that we're utilizing
existing technologies now whether 5g
there is there or not those technologies
will continue to be using i don't know
if this bill restricts the placement or
erection or construction of antennas
because they're 5g or not or if it's all
or nothing
thank you representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question
i can't reach my butt
my my concern is that the bill that we
are contemplating
is
more or less on the proliferation of
towers
no matter what's connected to them
and i
have some
expertise in the uh
interoperability situation because of
the sheriff's department
and our emergency
response
do you believe and uh that
proliferation of towers small towers
within a small radius of each other or
large towers within a sm
small rate is
better
for the service
than
what i would consider fiber optics do
you believe that those towers
in close proximity to each other
and in close proximity to certain
sensitive places
would enhance
our
speed of
and and and eliminate the dead zones
that's a hard question to answer um
because
i can wait on it
i'll give you the best answer that i can
how's that
i can tell you this that we when we
decide we and not only the department of
safety decide to look at areas in which
we need to provide coverage for our own
usage not for the individual communities
that are out there that are using radio
networks for their own purposes we look
at a number of things and we try to make
the best decision based upon available
technology as well as with the
infrastructure that we have to build to
put it in place and sometimes that means
the availability of high-speed fiber
optic or does it make better sense to
put in a microwave system that actually
allows us to
get that radio communications up and
maybe quicker for less expense to
provide to our public safety officials
and officers that are out on the street
the ability to communicate back to us
it's it
really the answer is it depends depends
on a number of things including all the
things i just spoke to does that answer
your question
may i respond go ahead and respond
somewhat
but i i
i'm i'm concerned about the security of
some of these places having
had a flat tire in a dead zone in dover
uh years ago
what
what do you believe that a new system
and a new system of towers can do
that fiber optics cannot do
and do you believe it's essential
and that's a great question and that
that question i think i can't answer and
thank you for it
we live in a state that has
a lot of urban areas that are covered
with a lot of coverage whether it's
broadband whether it's fiber optic
whether it's cellular connectivity and
then we live in a state that has a vast
section of area geography wise that's
not covered with that because it's
impractical from a business standpoint
to lay out fiber optic throughout the
north country out in the western part of
the state where it's just not practical
to do however when it comes to an
emergency response the emergency
response is not contingent upon
whether
that should be in place or not it's
contingent upon whether it is in place
or not when we talk about cellular
connectivity and lte and radio we're
looking to cross that span of those
areas that don't have broadband
connectivity where people can't go to
the wall and pick up a phone or reach
for their cell phone and know they're
going to have a signal because they live
in the urban area of the state in those
areas where we do a lot of wilderness
rescues and if you're paying attention
to the news you're seeing a lot of that
happen now
people are dependent upon that cellular
device that they have whether they
should be or not
they get stuck and then they're in a jam
on the side of a mountain someplace in
bad bad weather they want to know that
they've got a cellular connection it's
not going to happen everywhere but
they're not going to have fiber optic up
the side of a mountain to connect to
either okay mr doyle we really
appreciate your testimony thank you for
coming in this afternoon we've got six
more folks we want to hear from in the
next 40 minutes so i would like to call
now on
cecilia doucette of ashland
new hampshire and ms doucette
you're going to have three minutes
and i would remind you that we've
already heard testimony about
the technology of 5g we've heard
testimony about
the potential health effects that some
people feel if you can add
new information to what we've already
been told that would be appreciated
so you have
three minutes please begin
thank you my name is cecilia ducette and
i am the director of massachusetts for
safe technology and the international
nonprofit wireless education
i helped ashland public schools in
massachusetts become the first in the
nation to take precautions with wireless
technology i have also worked on several
bills in massachusetts and in other
states
as a pandemic taught us we need to be
vigilant about invisible toxins
science indicates we should be at 0.1
microwatts per square meter in our
sleeping areas
and no more than 1 000 outdoors
this uh one cell phone that i'm going to
turn in first i'll give you an ambient
reading of just everybody's devices and
the wireless access points that are
mounted throughout the building
okay
so i've just and the ambient was at 3
700.
but look what happens now when i have
turned my cell phone on
and i'm not even doing anything this is
just a cell phone going here i am where
are you here i am where are you to the
cell towers
and we are at 458
microwatts per square meter and we need
to be at 0.1 in our sleeping areas so
this is the gravity of what we are doing
here today
indoors all we need to do
who knew you can buy a little adapter
hook up to an ethernet cable and you can
plug your cell phone in here to access
the internet twenty dollars for an
adapter
when we allow any kind of close range
cell antennas or allow toxic utility
smart meters on our homes there is no
escape there is no sleep sanctuary and
the cumulative damage begins to mount
new hampshire's groundbreaking majority
report
is from highly qualified
doctors scientists engineers and
legislators they have documented for you
the science and the conflicts of
interest
with our captured federal agencies this
is all in the report
the meat of the report is in the first
17 pages so if you haven't read it yet
you will get the summary and 15
recommendations in those first 17 pages
i hope everybody has read this by now
in my earlier emails to you and
contributions to the subcommittee
meeting on january 31st 30 seconds i
debunked much of the disinformation
provided in the minority report that
starts on page 18.
we can have excellent technology and
close the digital divide but only with
future proof high speed cable or fiber
to and through the premises with
responsibly sighted
cellular microwave systems for
emergencies
the fcc already i'm sorry the cdc
already has the alara principle which
means as low as reasonably achievable
and as dr swanson mentioned that's for
x-rays gamma rays in the sun we need to
apply alara now that we know just how
toxic microwave radiation is at the
non-thermal
level thank you thank you very much do
we have questions for ms doucette
representative white has a question
thank you you uh mentioned 0.1
microwatts for sleeping locations what's
that based on that's based on this
compendium called the bio initiative
report which has
literally hundreds if not thousands of
peer-reviewed published scientific
literature and it was done with 14
international experts who are experts in
the biological effects we need to get
away
from listening to engineers
and physicists and technologists when we
set
biological safety limits we need to
listen to
the peer-reviewed independent science
representative callie pitts is
recognized for a question i'm really
sorry that i'm i but i
is there any
to your knowledge
is there any adverse effect
on medical equipment
from close proximity
to these microwaves i remember years ago
when microwave
ovens first came out big warnings all
over the place if you have a pacemaker
don't go near it um
i i just wondered if that has changed or
if there's more
data on that to your knowledge that has
not changed it is
a cause of interference
follow-up
so on medical equipment like
pacemakers oxygen tents
different things especially near
hospitals or in private homes
would it still perhaps have an effect
it can
representative knotter is recognized for
a question thank you mr chairman and
thank you for taking the question have
any 5g bills passed in massachusetts
we have not had a 5g bill passed in
massachusetts
thank you
thank you okay miss doucet seeing no
further questions we thank you very much
for your testimony and we now call on
james hancock of west chesterfield new
hampshire
mr hancock you have three minutes thank
you hi there um i uniquely straddle both
the engineering side and the medical
side of this uh debate
as one of the leaders at northern
telecom building 2g back in the 1990s
that resulted in almost all the base
stations for 2g in both the united
states and canada and as the creator of
the pop mednet system that is the
backbone for all distributed uh
epidemiology in the united states and 23
other countries so i am uniquely
qualified to talk about the statistics
and the probabilities of problems to do
with this and the engineering
consequences of this so
just to give an example right now people
have asked specific questions i think
it's best of my time to actually answer
some questions what is 5g well 5g is
literally wi-fi 6. there's literally no
difference between wi-fi
with the latest version
and 5g there's none there are identical
standards
there's no difference that's number one
number two 5g is 15 to 20 percent more
efficient than 4g over the same
frequency over the same megahertz it is
simply a more
efficient encoding standard
it is not in any way unique and these
waves are used everywhere in fact if you
take that device
and go and hold it over a cable
television
cable you will get exactly the same
interference with exactly the same
waveform
as you do for 5g and wi-fi because they
both use exactly the same protocol all
three of them do
okay in fact if we hold that device in
front of an led light bulb you will get
similar rates of radiation if you hold
it near an electrical socket you'll get
similar rates of radiation
the key is is that it's different
frequencies but the key with frequency
is the higher the frequency the less it
goes through a wall in fact what the
community i believe is actually worried
about is what's called millimeter wave
it's high frequency
12 gigahertz to about 80 gigahertz well
if you've got a car that has collision
avoidance you're broadcasting all the
time at significantly high water higher
wattage than all millimeter wave
broadcast uh in 5g
okay if you have a television set you
are broadcast that is less than five
years old you're broadcasting at 60
hertz you 60 gigahertz using exactly the
same frequency if you
step outside and you enjoy the fact that
your weather forecast told you exactly
how the weather was 30 seconds you are
literally experiencing significantly
higher radiation on
significantly higher modulation from the
weather satellites that are broadcasting
down on you right now even sea band
which everybody's concerned about with
airports it literally was at thousands
of times more power with six foot
antennas in everybody's yards with
dishes and yet now we're talking 100
watts of power to give an example really
quickly there's a wi-fi antenna right
there using exactly the same encoding as
5g
it right now
is 42 negative 42 db okay and the lower
the number the worse it is my cell phone
on att right now
is negative 119 db that means that it's
about 17 times less powerful in this
room than the wi-fi that you're sitting
with okay using the same frequency
thank you that's great information do we
have committee uh
questions for
mr hancock
representative thomas is recognized for
a question thank you mr chair thank you
for this question just out of curiosity
how
how do you account
for the apparentness that there are
people that have testified
with having conditions
uh
ver of various sorts that seem to be
living within certain radiuses of these
type of this type of technology have you
personally heard of any issues
in your experience
yes and i'll i'll address it simply i
have celiac disease but celiac disease
wasn't actually a thing
until about 20 years ago
but did that mean that because we
discovered that celiac makes people
allergic to the proteins in wheat
does that mean that there was a massive
increase
in people that had celiac disease no we
discovered it we created science to
actually monitor it and empirically
discover what was going on autism is
another perfect example we're constantly
told that autism is called caused by
vaccinations and yet with 95 percent
assured this a professional in autism
can diagnose a child with autism and i
know because my wife is one at 95
percent accuracy before their first
vaccination
okay the key is is that we now think of
autism as an epidemic in this country
but what it actually is is that until
1990 we didn't actually have a solid
definition for autism nor did we have
the science to actually discover it so
we've gone and attributed
causation
to correlation caused by increased
testing we've even seen this with covet
19 we massively increased the testing in
the state and then breathlessly reported
that the number of cases is way up
did we prove anything no what we proved
is is that if you test more you'll get
more cases the exactly the same thing is
happening here so these events and i'm
not denying that they that they happen
and in fact i would absolutely guarantee
that there are people that are actually
susceptible to emf radiation but it's
not just cell phone radiation it's all
radiation which is everywhere
but we now know what it is and we have
ways to test for it and empirically
identify it so it appears to be have
become a much more significant problem
when it hasn't
we just know about it
thank you
thank you representative samsich is
recognized for a question
thank you mr chairman thank you for
coming testifying and giving us a lot of
interesting information um can you tell
me if you are con
convinced that
the 5g technology is somehow essential
to what what we all
benefit from now with the all the
technologies
uh is there is there no other way around
this
the the needs that we have
and um
so so you do you see that technology is
somehow essential to be installed so
that's a two-part question first of all
yes we could all go and wire into plugs
in the walls
okay but the radiation of putting in all
those wells what's there 50 60 people in
this room okay so if we were to go and
wire everybody in this room every single
person would actually have to have an
ethernet cable and even though the
ethernet cables are insulated you just
put 50 to 60 more in every single room
that are broadcasting on exactly the
same technology as 5g on those wires
that's broadcasting out of the walls
you're literally going to make every
single wall filled with cables just as
bad
okay and realistically is everybody
going to carry around a big 10-foot
cable in their pocket and plug in their
cell phone to go and use it
no
so the choice is are you going to
actually do something like that and then
in the remote community the
in the community has made an example
with emergency services
the what's the first thing that burns
down
you you've got you've got a furnace in a
school
which is probably the most likely
location for there to be a fire for
emergency services to have to respond to
well guess where they keep all of their
telecommunications equipment with their
their fiber optics their switches and
even all the ethernet that you want to
go and walk around and plug your cell
phone in that you're gonna have the
emergency services well they're in the
utility room right beside the boiler
room so as soon as that fire happens
even if you could convince anybody that
emergency services could viably go and
plug in
to be able to get their data on site
it's not going to exist because it's the
first thing to burn
okay and i'll be just there's one more
point to this is that a tnt so so
there's a misconception with 5g that 5g
requires lte as well that's a temporary
situation in fact t-mobile is right now
actively rolling out 5g that does not
require lte
and a t even on the emergency services
network has said within the next three
years that the entire emergency service
network in the entire country is
transitioning to 5g and while that isn't
an issue right now in three years if new
hampshire was to pass this new hampshire
would be the only state that would be
massively underserved and the technology
would rot because all of a t's equipment
that it's purchasing would not be
allowed to be used in the state so our
technology would rot it would fall apart
the technology won't be built because
there will be no customer for it
and as a result over time our emergency
services network on lte will fail
so if we don't allow 5g then absolutely
emergency services will not have
wireless communication in this state
representative mcgee is recognized for a
question thank you mr chairman and thank
you mr hancock for coming in today
i this makes me pleased that we do have
engineers
but uh
the question that i have is at the
beginning of your testimony you
mentioned that 5g was wi-fi 6. and you
also mentioned that
that this technology is 15 to 20 percent
more efficient which is i assume why it
can handle more data
uh so that's the expectation is that it
would be worth
just to answer that so
so 5g is 15 to 20 more efficient per
megahertz okay of signal so my phone
right now has 10 megahertz
if i was to download a video off the
internet with 4g
and 5g in that same 10 megahertz it
would download 15 to 20 more quickly on
exactly the same thing with 5g than 4g
however 5g is solely being deployed in
new frequencies that the fcc has
released that are much much larger so as
an example t-mobile bought sprint
bought 150 megahertz
of frequency and 2.5 gigahertz
okay versus which is four times larger
than all of the rest of the bandwidth
that they had in the state of new
hampshire so as a result they
immediately quadrupled the amount of
data that they can handle over over the
airwaves that they own but
there is no 4g
in that spectrum in the new c band the
new 3.5 3.8 gigahertz and millimeter
wave we're talking orders of magnitude
as an example t-mobile has 800 megahertz
of millimeter wave frequency if you
wanted to cover
the mancha manchester uh stadium you
can't do it using regular traditional
frequencies because there's simply not
enough bandwidth
you have to use
ultra high ultra wide band
communications of which there's simply
no technology because new hampshire
would be the only one
that will actually work in those
frequencies using old lte or even 3g or
any other follow-up mr chairman
follow up so
does that mean
all of that that you just said does that
mean bigger pipe yes much much bigger
okay thank you representative callie
pitts you have a very quick question i
don't know if it's quick but it's i'm
confused because
when we heard testimony we heard that 5g
piggybacks 4g
and it sounded to me and it this is
marketing terms what you are saying
is
and
forgive me if i'm wrong and correct me
that if we don't roll out this 4g we're
all stuck without
self-service 5g there's 5g
and i
that's a very scary in my mind
prospect
that i won't be able to pick up my phone
and call 9-1-1
that's true i don't believe
that that is the case so can you please
correct me to say that
if we don't use this particular service
who we don't know who manufacture it
matches it that maybe in five years
we're all gonna be stuck without service
and that
everything in new hampshire is gonna rot
i thought that
my impression was that 5 4g
was still going to be operable so
correct me
so
5g was rushed to market
as a
as a pitch
that should not have been released to
the market when it was released but
companies rushed it to market
that's why it required lte service to be
able to uplink back to the towers
however that's changing it's called
that's called nr or new radio
sa which is standalone 5g
is already being deployed right now by
t-mobile if you have a 5g phone in new
hampshire on t-mobile and it says 5g
you're solely broadcasting using 5g
technology at t verizon's new 5g network
it all is sa meaning standalone does not
require lte we know who the manufacturer
of these
devices are but this is if you go and
draw a parallel we're still to this day
until very very recently using 2g for
voice and sms text messaging okay and
the reason why we did this is because it
was vastly incompatible
except when lte came along for the first
time because 3g didn't even have voice
when lte came along we actually made it
all work like voiceover ip just like the
stuff that's used on a on most landlines
is voice over ip off of fiber optics
all of all of the cell phone companies
now if you have an lte signal your voice
is actually over that voice over ip well
the key is is that 5g
works with voice over ip exactly the
same way as lte and they're completely
interoperable so what will happen is
unlike the past where 2g stuck around
for decades
when it comes to 5g
4g is not going to stick around for
decades and the reality of engineering
is is that the reason why things cost
what they do is because of mass
purchases
so if new hampshire is the only state
left and everybody else has gone to 5g
and new hampshire can't
there isn't going to be a cost benefit
analysis to produce the minor number
we're talking thousands of units at most
instead of millions of units to be able
to maintain and replace 4g lte towers
with more 4g lte service because
literally everyone else will have gone
to 5g in fact the 5g consortium which
includes every single one of the cell
carriers in new hampshire expects that
within the next seven years that lte
will be disconnected decommissioned so
instead of 20 to 30 years for 2g we're
talking five to seven years okay
well thank you very much mr hancock this
has been very good information i still
have four people who would like to
testify so i would like to
move along and call next
terry clark from keene new hampshire
mr clark i'm going to give you three
minutes please thank you thank you very
much uh my name is terry clark and i'm a
county commissioner from cheshire county
uh i was a member of the keene city
council in 2019 when uh staff brought in
an ordinance to us that set guidelines
for installing small cell antennas in
the public right of way
and the problem the council faced was
that
it wasn't legal apparently
the council couldn't really consider
health effects in determining the
guidelines
uh
but the ordinance did include
non-binding preferences for location
standards but they were ignored when a
wireless company applied for licenses to
install these small cells in clustered
neighborhoods and
very close to elementary schools keene's
largest elementary school in fact
now i understand the federal
communications commission's a small sell
order which restricts what
municipalities can require our providers
in my mind it simply failed the citizens
of keene by by not enabling the city
council to make rules protecting
neighborhoods and schools
and i think this bill would would fix
that
peer review studies uh have convinced me
that bombarding humans with high
frequency radio wave bandwidth is
harmful
as a background i served in an air
defense artillery unit in the early
1970s
and at the time there were discussions
then about new technologies which
using high frequency radio waves could
not only disrupt
electrical systems and communications
equipment but could also heat human skin
levels uh immobilizing enemy soldiers
and they were talking about the
bandwidth of a millimeter wave which is
between 30 gigahertz and 300 gigahertz
the range of 5g technology uses
um
if we're going to use this kind of
technology well
let me just say that
my fear is is that we've gotten away
from
discussing the health effects of this
technology with the emergence of a
multi-billion dollar
communications industry probably
trillions of dollars
the the military uh at the time decided
not to pursue this because
it violated many of the international
treaties that we had
for weapon systems and things and it was
discovered that it
shuts that thing wouldn't be humane way
to kill people
in any case
at the time i had a particular uh
grade level
and expertise in the area and uh uh
um
30 seconds i can talk okay i could talk
more intelligently about it than i can
right now because
i've been out of the industry but
i agree with the state commission that
the fcc
based the small cell order on outdated
and incomplete findings i don't think
that we've really been talking about the
safety
and health
uh of of this kind of technology just
because we have technology now
that we've been using we really don't
know the effect of what we're using
right now long-term effect on people now
this state which is proud of its home
root heritage home rule heritage needs
legislation that enables municipalities
to protect its citizens from sometimes
rash decisions that we get into that in
the past have all too frequently been
made in the interest of progress
okay thank you i really appreciate your
testimony are there questions um
for this gentleman
seeing none i will call on the next
person who has signed up to testify
and that would be
russian or russian
chester of bedford
thank you committee chair thank you
committee members three minutes please
absolutely so i'm coming here
specifically as a citizen
but i do want to let you folks know that
i have experience with
this kind of situation when i worked for
a private
company that
handled
almost all of the weaponry for our
military
the 5g
clearly is the same type of
resources that they had developed
so does phi is 5g a weapon i don't know
does it have the potential to be a
weapon absolutely
similar to nuclear power
nuclear power is supposedly extremely
safe but anytime we hear the word
nuclear
we automatically think of the nuclear
bomb
so i just want to bring that to your
attention more importantly as a
someone who
has traumatic brain injury
i
used to be
very much um
a cons
not a conspiracy theorist about the
tinfoil hats and all that kind of stuff
and i still don't know for sure if my
traumatic brain injury and my
sensitivity
has increased because of that traumatic
brain injury and if it interacts with
radio waves what i do know that when i
worked
with children with traumatic brain
injury infant all the way up
um or or acquired brain injury um that
they could be asleep in the car
and we could go by a cell tower that was
very close and they would cry out
do i know why no
but has it happened on a number of
occasions absolutely
so i just want you folks to really
consider that when you're thinking about
something like this i've heard time and
time and time again we can't be left
behind the people of new hampshire want
it
if they knew the potential consequences
would they really want it
thank you
uh any questions for miss jester
seeing none i will thank you for your
testimony
and i will now call on the next person
the next two folks on our list are both
from
out of state and the first is deborah
chandler of south hadley massachusetts
haven't we seen you before you don't
look like
i apologize deborah came to my house
last night and i'll explain what
happened
my name is deborah chandler i suffer
from microwave radiation syndrome after
i was here to testify on january 18th
but didn't get to speak it took me five
days to recover
from three hours of exposure in this
room from everyone's laptops tablets
smartphones wearables and that wi-fi
access point i could not take that risk
again so i have asked cc doucet to read
this statement on my behalf
please create an accommodation under the
americans with disabilities act so those
injured by wireless radiation can
testify remotely from the safety of our
own radiation free homes
subsequent to courtney gilardi and her
daughter amelia testifying before you
two weeks ago about the cell tower that
made their neighborhood so sick
the board of health in pittsfield
massachusetts has a has issued a
groundbreaking
cease and desist order against verizon
wireless cell tower
it is the board of health's lawful duty
to protect the public health and the
telecom act preemption apparently
applies only to the permitting process
not to what happens after the cell
towers are turned on
this first poster that deb she's a she
was a graphic artist she had to leave
her profession when she became ill
this first poster illustrates common
symptoms suffered when a cell tower goes
up and you will see brain damage ears
skin mood eye heart and others
the new hampshire 5g commission report
includes the bio initiative report a
compendium that i that i showed you a
little bit ago
of the peer-reviewed scientific
literature there are color charts
available at bioinitiative.org
to help the public understand the
science we see
in the key down at the bottom
the categories of disrupted immune
function fertility effects
oxidative damage dna repair failure
brain tumors cancers cardiac damage and
issues with sleep neuron firing rate
memory learning and behavior
you'll also see these studies spanned
decades this one she pointed out was
nearly 50 years ago
the industry has known about this since
the 1990s
despite the denials and disinformation
they have given to you
the pittsfield public health tragedy and
so many others like it could have been
prevented had there been a federal law
in place for bidding cell towers and
antennas at close range
there isn't though so it's up to our
states to ensure responsible technology
deployment new hampshire can still have
cell care coverage if you require
industry to site antennas away from the
public the phone signals can travel for
miles 30 seconds some may be tempted to
negotiate the 1 640 foot distance in
house bill 1644 but that is already half
of where the science still shows
increases in cancers neurological orders
and more
dr kent chamberlain who's with us today
and served on that commission provided
you each with a video to understand
these setbacks at the 10 minute mark
you'll see increased death rates start
to drop off at 500 meters or
1640 feet but there are still elevated
risks up to nearly a thousand meters or
three thousand feet okay thank you
that's uh
that's all we have time for i do have
one quick question for you do you know
of any epidemiological studies about
this question yes in dr chamberlain's
presentation he is referencing the
epidemiological studies great thank you
i'll look that up okay okay any
questions for
ms uh
chandler's surrogate
representative christian
thank you chair for recognizing me thank
you for taking my question um so i took
a look through the bio initiative report
and i have to confess i found it a
little bit
hard to follow some of the
specific mechanisms that they were
proposing was causing these damages
could you talk a little bit more about
mechanism
so for a long time the industry could
spin it that well it must be fine
because we don't have any mechanisms of
harm identified that is no longer true
one of the mechanisms of harms occurs at
the voltage-gated calcium channels so
when we have this spike of radiation
hitting our biological cells at millions
of times in the gigahertz range or
billions of times or i'm sorry in the
megahertz range billions of times in the
gigahertz range it's doing this to our
cells that disrupts the voltage-gated
calcium channels it causes them
to have a chemical reaction outside the
cell wall that produces a really nasty
free radical called peroxynitrite peroxy
nitrite then will go into your body and
have a host of downstream effects for
you it might be breast cancer for you it
might be testicular cancer for you it
might be heart or brain
so wherever your body's weakest
proclivity is that's where we see harm
developing
another mechanism of harm is called the
rouleaux effect
so when i was a kid i used to love those
candies called rolos that stack up
that's what happens when you magnetize
our red blood cells they should be
individually free floating and
oxygenating all of our biological cells
when you have
this magnetic field it's causing our red
blood cells to form the rouleaux effect
or this clumping and then that clump
can't get to where it needs to go
to bring oxygen to all of our systems at
the emf medical conference that was held
last january those courses are still
available today the doctors talked a lot
about that reload effect and they also
talked a lot about
when you put up a cell tower outside
somebody's house or a smart meter on
their home that's where they see an
increased patient load of people
suffering from microwave sickness so
those are only two of the effects there
are many more that we could discuss
infertility is a really big one too
all right we have one more person who
would like to testify so i would like to
call now on frank clegg
from
maple shore village or maple grove
village in ontario canada oakville
ontario canada
thank you very much
chairman vos
mr clegg could not be here but he asked
me to read his statement
esteemed committee can you do so in
three minutes i will
um esteemed committee members my name is
frank clegg and i'm the retired
president of microsoft canada and
founder of canadians for safe technology
i flew in to testify with you in 2019 on
representative abrami's original house
bill 522
and i'm one of the experts brought in
for the 5g commission investigation
i've met with scientific experts from
around the world and conducted concluded
wireless technology is not safe
i'm especially concerned with 5g and the
impact of wireless technologies on
children
your groundbreaking new hampshire
commission report has become a guidepost
not only in the u.s but here in canada
and europe as well the 640 foot setback
will protect new hampshire citizens from
any new wireless infrastructure in the
short term as your commission report
indicates though the ultimate goal is to
install superior fiber to and through
the premises
please know wireless technology is no
longer the preferred technology for
communications there are an
insignificant number of applications
that truly require a wireless connection
the majority of communications
applications can benefit from the
advantages of a wired connection
wired connectivity eliminates harmful
radio frequency or rf radiation
wired broadband is at least 100 times
faster more reliable and resilient and
is far more protective of privacy than
wireless connectivity
according to the ieee wireless
technologies quote consume at least 10
times more power than wired technologies
a 5g base station is expected to consume
roughly three times as much power as a
4g base station
greenpeace reports if the cloud were a
country it would be the largest
fifth largest consumer of energy in the
world
former fcc chair tom wheeler is now
backing fiverr to the premises
at t is already moving there
in july california passed legislation
for fiber to the premises
in switzerland the raimonda energy
company and the swiss fournette telecom
communi
company have already formed a new
alliance for fiber to the home as they
call it
fiber to the premises solves the
broadband equity issues finally closing
the digital divide
the cost is not prohibitive wherever we
run electricity lines we can insert
fiber optics
properly cited cell towers carry signal
for miles and do not need to be located
near the populace the industry however
has a history of installing where it is
convenient and less costly for them
right on top of neighborhoods where the
electrical connections already exist
once we install fiber to and through the
premises and educate the public to
minimize toxic wireless connections 30
seconds the capacity demands for
wireless diminish and there is ample
capacity for cell phone calls on the go
investing in fibre to the premises for
primary connectivity will bring an
economic boon to new hampshire the
industry started as the cellular
telecommunications industry association
then they rebranded as ctia the wireless
association they're already preparing
their next revenue stream by buying into
the entertainment industry for streaming
services the industry will grumble but
they will pivot to provide superior
connectivity with fiber to and through
the premises okay thank you so much
thank you very much um
since that's written testimony if you
could make sure mr clegg submits it to
the committee via email we would
appreciate that
so uh
it's been brought to my attention that
there is one other person who
wants to testify on this bill someone
who has driven all the way up here from
pennsylvania
and so against my better judgment i'm
going to allow this person to testify
for three minutes
so mr eric swanson i believe that's uh
how the name is pronounced you're
recognized to testify for three minutes
thank you
thank you mr chair and thank you for
allowing me the three minutes
my name is eric swanson i've been asked
to talk to you about health effects of
this technology by ctia
i'm a professor of physics at the
university of pittsburgh i'm a member of
the union of concerned scientists and
i'm a fellow of the american physical
society
the technology we're talking about is
non-ionizing radio waves non-ionizing
means that it is below what's called the
ionization threshold where
electromagnetic radiation has enough
energy to disrupt chemical processes
because this technology 5g in particular
is 30 000 times below that energy it has
no verified
effects on human body except for heating
because of this heating the fcc
regulates this technology the
regulations are extremely strict i won't
give you the numbers
i would like to point out that some of
the things you've heard are completely
wrong so please ask me questions
afterwards
if you like
i won't give you numbers but let me give
you comparisons my brain is is a radio
transmitter i can explain why if you're
interested
it violates fcc regulations by about a
factor of 10. the sun violates fcc
regulations by about a factor of 16.
my hot water bottle that i put on my
knee this morning because it was warm
violates fcc regulations by about a
factor of 50.
as you might gather from what i saying
these regulations are extremely strict
and protect us very well
i'll stop there because i know you're
short of time but i'm very happy to
answer questions
mr swanson would love to hear your
questions representative the wiki is
recognized my question thank you mr
chairman and thank you mr swanson for
taking my question one of the things
that i've been trying to get to is what
is the spectrum power and frequency and
i keep hearing different answers from
different people and so
um when we're talking about uh cell
phones whether it's 5g or otherwise
we've got 800 1600 megahertz and so on
and so forth what amount of power do we
get at that how does that compare with
the ambient radiation from radio
stations right so so good question thank
you um you mentioned power and frequency
so frequencies are higher there they can
go up to 30 gigahertz they are typically
right now at one gigahertz that's a
factor of 30 higher so the higher one
remembers 30 000 times below the limit
um the power you don't get a definitive
answer that because there isn't one it
depends on the situation the the
companies are very proprietary about all
this they typically for 5g though are
very low compared to the 4g towers that
out there they will run at something
like 20 to 40 watts the towers would be
say 400 watts for comparison your laptop
is about 100 watts
further questions for mr swanson
representative bernardi is recognized
thank you mr chairman uh and thank you
professor um
so the bill that we have in front of us
limits uh
distance for these towers do you see
that as inhibiting
the proliferation of 5g technology
yes it does
it's also nonsensical
if you stand at the base of one of these
high power 4g towers you'll be at 1
1000th of the fcc limit which is very
strict if you limit the density of the
5g then you may as well not have 5g it's
designed to be low power and dense
that's the whole idea you get less
you know there's less immediate exposure
when you make it low power but you have
more of them
follow-up
so what would be your recommendation
then that the industry should seek for
its density how far apart should these
towers be
if we're talking about five yeah if
we're talking about 5g it's the sights
and they typically will be
it depends again on on details but
typically a block apart
again they're very low power to all of
our benefit higher more reliable
communication and less exposure
thank you
representative substance is recognized
for a question thank you mr chairman
thank you mr swanson for coming to
testify um
it seems to me that the the main
incentive for the 5g deployment has to
do with
with business
please ask a question so don't make a
statement i
so yeah so i'm i don't don't understand
that uh
the reason behind it would be a health
effect i think
wouldn't you agree that the main
motivation for for this 5g rollout is
not health benefits but basically
business driven i'm i'm sure that the
main motivation is to is to provide
customers with the services they they
desire it's not so much about health yes
representative callie pitts has a
question
quickly you mentioned the uh standing at
the base of a a cell tail which i have
never done
but what would happen
or what is the cumulative effect
of me
constantly
walking by or living near a cell tower
and having it outside my door
and i i
i don't understand that correlation
that's a fair question
there actually is no cumulative effect i
can explain this best with an analogy
say that i want to throw a rock across a
river the river's too wide i can't get
the rock across now i i'm stubborn so i
keep trying to throw the rock across the
river
am i going to get the rock across no
the same thing happens with this there
is not enough energy in these 5g waves
to disrupt anything and it doesn't
matter how long you stand there it's
still not going to disrupt anything for
basically exactly the same river as i
said with the rock throwing so sorry the
same reason i said with the rock
throwing
okay thank you any uh further questions
for
representative mcgee is recognized thank
you mr chairman okay so this
my question is we just heard some
testimony again taking notes here
um
we just heard some testimony
about
uh bio effects basically
um
i'm trying to find the notes
voltage
gated calcium channels being disrupted
and
my notes are all over the place so i'm
sorry
and uh and the in the ruler effect so i
don't know if you know anything about
those things but i just wonder if you
have any impressions on that i'm i'm
happy to to give you a
sort of an overview of this stuff
i hear about this all the time it's all
wrong all of it and i want to explain
why this even exists
the medical industry standard for
conducting a study is is to work at a
five percent false positive level it's
called alpha
all medical studies
desire to have a five percent false
positive level meaning that if you run a
hundred studies five of them are going
to find something that's the definition
of the false positive level
twenty five thousand studies have been
done estimated by the world health
organization five percent of that is
about a thousand about a thousand
studies are going to find something now
what do they find it's random remember
it's a false positive rate so they find
random stuff
and it's all over the map and the reason
it's all over the map and the reason you
get such a long laundry list of
disastrous things
is because it's random
when people focus on those thousand
studies the five percent they are
ignoring the 95 percent of studies that
don't find any effect whatsoever it's of
course it's natural instinct of course
it just oh that agrees with my viewpoint
i'm going to pay attention to that and
ignore the 95 percent that disagree with
you
that's what underpins all of this stuff
thank you
well
this has been a very informative hour
and seven minutes unfortunately it
cannot continue because we are committed
by schedule to
open an exec session
open exec sessions on five early bills
so we're going to close the public
hearing on house bill 1644
and i'm going to ask all spectators and
members of the minority party
oh yes representative pimentel would you
give us the blue sheet numbers please
while representative pimentel is looking
i'm going to ask all members of the
public
and members of the minority party to
exit the room for
two minutes while we have a quick caucus
of the majority party
uh mr chairman there are uh six names on
the blue cheek
four of them are
a
pro and two of them are khan
and i also have a copy of the house
remote testimony
which i don't know you have but
it shows 155
pro
excuse me uh four pro
155 con and one neutral
thank you okay
we will resume in two minutes
the mic
testing testing
okay ladies and gentlemen please take
your seats quietly i would like to
resume our
exec session
and i want to begin by apologizing to
everyone for the late start of this
executive session it was supposed to
start at two o'clock
and i did my best to make that happen
but was unsuccessful
so i apologize for that and uh apologize
for any
inconvenience that this late start may
have caused anyone i personally feel
very strongly
that it's disrespectful for committee
meetings of this sort
not to start on time because it wastes
people's valuable time and everyone here
has
time that is valuable to them
and the causes that they espouse
so my apologies for the late start
with that
i will open an exact session on house
bill
1419 dash fn
relative to establishing a new hampshire
civilian climate corps advisory
commission
and the chair recognizes
jose representative cam brills for a
motion
thank you mr chair i would like to make
a motion to recommend
that we itl house bill 1419.
representative cambrils has moved that
we
judge
hb 1419 to be itl chair recognizes
representative pleasure
yes thank you chair i would like to
second that motion on house bill 14 14
19 to itl okay it has been moved and
seconded that we itl house bill 1419 is
there any discussion
representative oxenom is recognized
i'd like to hear
an explanation of why you think this
bill should be
itled
representative cambril
do you want to respond
yes i thank you mr chair and thank you
for the question
yes basically even there were a lot of
uh good things that were mentioned
that the climate corps civilian chemical
group could do but after researching i
found that almost every single thing
that they recommended that would be
duties of this
commission are already being done by
existing groups such as the
department of environmental services
department of energy
fish and game
so i viewed this to be a redundant
commission
and i did not think it would be a wise
use of the taxpayers money so for that
reason
i am recommending to itl thank you
further discussion on the motion to
itl hb 1419 representative bernardi is
recognized
yes in addition to uh what
representative kimbrell's indicated many
of the tasks were also
activities that are currently conducted
by private businesses and we should not
be setting up commissions that interfere
with private business activities
further discussion
samsic is recognized
thank you mr tim
well i would i would
say that i'd like to see us support this
this bill
we hear over and over again from state
agencies how they are out overstretched
they can't do all their job they need
more people
to say that these functions are being
done by state agencies right now
i would be shocked if that was actually
the case because it's certainly within
their domain to do it but i doubt very
much that much is being done in this
direction
but the main thrust of this particular
bill was to energize and activate and
get people involved especially young
people who feel strongly they want to
contribute they want to volunteer to
their state and do something that they
feel strongly about
and
this bill is is not a costly bill it's
it's it's a very simple bill it's all
about volunteerism and getting young
people and people interested in climate
issues and environment involved and to
say that we don't and this is not even
instituting that program it's just about
a committee who's going to study this
so i don't see why we shouldn't be
supporting it
representative kelly pitts is recognized
i
i too would
hope that we could support it because
we have an in testimony that i just
heard piecemeal efforts being done in
various state agencies and various
businesses
and i would think that it is
to have a comprehensive commission to
put all this together
and perhaps eliminate some of that
redundancy
would be well served
way back
we had ccc
conservation corps
and they did marvelous work but they
mimicked
the work of other groups
so having something for young people and
maybe
consolidating that effort at this time
would not be a bad idea
we are all stewards of the planet
every one of us whether we believe in
climate change or whether we don't
we are to be stewards
we don't
own it
we're to take care of it and that that's
what most of us believe
and i think that raising young people or
teaching young people that would be a
wonderful thing
and consolidating those efforts so that
more people would be aware of them
would be well worth it
thank you
thank you representative nader is
recognized for a comment
thank you mr chairman uh in my community
we have volunteers that go out and pick
up trash and and take care of the
environment and i support that without
using taxpayer dollars
further comment on the motion to itl
house bill 1419 representative mann is
recognized yes
thank you mr chairman um
young people have to live in the future
which is
distinctly different uh from my
prospects
and most of us in fact and i think uh
civilian conservation corps would be
a way for them to participate in
and actively and do something for their
own future which they probably
would be dying to do if they
gave we gave them half a chance thank
you
thank you representative pementel is
recognized for a comment thank you mr
chairman um
some of the things mentioned was that a
lot of other agencies are doing
stuff about this well i contend that
this
advisory commission is a place where we
can bring together the des and the
department of
energy
and department of education
and a lot of non-profits
that are in the state
and uh
work out
how this com how this
uh civilian climate core
could work
not a penny would be spent until
after they come up with a pro with a
program
and at that point it would go to the
legislature
as a bill to actually establish this
core so i think that
uh
basically
putting the knicks to this this this
early
is not a good idea and i'm going to be
supporting this bill
representative thomas is recognized for
a comment thank you mr chair mr chair
i do believe this is a good endeavor but
like other good endeavors i don't see a
need for why the state would have to get
involved and establish a commission
there are a lot of organizations out
there that are done by
volunteers
organized organizations formed as
non-profits they all do good deeds i
don't see why a private organization
of any sort could not be established
without you know this
this bill to accomplish the same needs i
i just don't see why the state should be
getting involved with this i mean even
you can substitute this for saying we
should have a commission on how we can
get involved with sports in the state
you know yet we have numerous
non-profit volunteer state associations
that are being run without the state's
help
so i don't think this bill is necessary
i think the idea is fair for people that
want to get involved with us and they
should form something but i don't think
this bill is the right way to go i'll be
voting against it
thank you representative the wiki is
recognized for a comment thank you mr
chairman representative thomas stole my
thunder that was exactly what i was
saying if it's a good idea then why
can't it be voluntary
additional comments uh representative uh
christian has a comment
thank you um so my understanding of the
bill is that you know it's meant to
serve as a place for government to bring
together
um
in addition to
there's a lot of volunteer organizations
and nonprofit organizations that are
going to be part of this but part of it
is also the idea that there will be um
you know some government federal money
uh coming in for these sorts of things
um so just speaking as a younger person
in the legislature i guess um
you know when i look around at things
that we've done in this country
historically things that were built by
the wpa and the ccc and still last today
it's really powerful that idea that we
can build things that last for a really
long time when we work together
and going back to what representative
mann said earlier
you know we think about young people
today feel so alienated from their
community maybe this is a great way that
we can bring together
people from young people from all over
to work together build something
together and hopefully have a more civil
discourse
along all kinds of
topics so thank you
thank you representative creation
since you mentioned it i will also
mention that the civilian conservation
corps back in the 1930s was formed was
created by the government in a time when
there was 25 percent or more
uh unemployed
unemployment in our country today we
have the opposite problem we have more
jobs and we have people to fill them
further comments on this uh
representative man has another comment
yes i um in a
in contrast to the idea why can't people
just do it on their own i think the um
what what the civilian core could do is
provide organization
and resources you're doing work in
terms of energy efficiency so and so on
and improving our
prospects in terms of climate change it
will take resources
far beyond what
i think individuals can
find in their pockets
thank you mr speaker mr chairman
thank you representative man
representative samsic is recognized
thank you mr chairman
um
i'm old enough to remember when this
country still had a draft and when the
draft was abolished
and when people no longer were forced
to provide service to the government
military-wise
a lot of things
dropped off the edge
people felt oh i don't have to do
anything for my country anymore you know
no more draft
but in fact
there was
there was still the peace corps
and if you remember what the peace corps
had as an impact first of all it was
mainly young people that joined and
secondly it projected a vision of
america and
a portrait of america to the rest of the
world
that positive impression
lasted many many decades after after it
started to dwindle and now has become
more something that seniors do instead
of young people do
i personally always felt that there
needs to be some kind of mandatory
national service in this country for
everybody
so that everybody should do something in
service of their country whether it's
peace corps or a military or
something
similar
i think citizens have to have some
obligations and right now they don't
they take it for granted that somebody
else will do this for them
this is an opportunity to do something
that might energize
young people and energize other people
to say i'd like to do something when it
comes to the climate or energy
efficiency or the environment
and
government needs to be there to help
organize something like this it might
turn out to be very inexpensive after
all uh peace corps workers were pretty
cheap too back then so i think for those
reasons we really should consider
encouraging these things and not
discouraging them thank you
representative notter is recognized
thank you mr chairman i have an example
of the community coming together without
the government sticking their nose in it
in the town of merrimack a few years
back the rotary club organized a
rebuilding twin bridge park and it was
just a vast array of people old people
grandparents parents and young people as
well all working together they
renovated kids cove that's what we call
twin bridge park and it's really nice
and the government had nothing to do
with it and it worked well
thank you representative callie pitts
i have two observations and i'll go to
the last one first representative notter
what if i wanted to help rebuild a park
in your community i would not have known
anything about it so that consolidation
and a place to go the other piece of
information
that i would like to
correct and i'm looking at
representative thomas and i hate to do
that but the government has stuck its
nose in sports
and it's only certain sports and i do
believe we have a commissioner of a
certain sport in this state
which is boxing
thank you
representative thomas is recognized
thank thank you mr chair um
uh
i'd like to go back to previous comments
made by representative samsich i agree
with you uh young people should take
responsibility
i do remember what time was the draft uh
based on your comments maybe the federal
government should reinstate the draft
to have people uh to do work for their
country but i think it would be best
served that if this was
that idea that you're speaking of
perhaps it should be the federal
government that establishes something
and not just a patchwork of state by
state
so i would think that new hampshire
should perhaps if this is that important
should wait and see if the federal
government would like to establish a
national program in which the state
could perhaps join in as a state
association on something like that so
it's my comments on that and by the way
yes
representative kelly pitts
boxing does have a commissioner
but
soccer does not i don't know why but we
do quite well here in the state have our
own private association on that one so
thank you
thank you representative mirner is
recognized for a comment thank you
chairman um in the 70s late 70s we had a
similar program in this country because
we had very high unemployment
and being in the construction trades we
we created the cedar program
again it was based on employment you
know the government did fund it and we
amazing amount of stuff got done back
then
because back then we were at 11
unemployment for a couple of years right
now we have no unemployment to chairman
fose's point so i can't see how this
program would work i think we'd be
throwing
into something that's just not
sustainable to do at this time thank you
occidum has another comment
yes
first i'd like to point out that the
federal funds under the american rescue
plan are cited in the fiscal note those
would not be available to voluntary
organizations
or to rotary organizations
secondly we have a demographic crisis in
this state we're losing our young people
we're losing them to better
opportunities elsewhere and because of
despair but what i hear and what i
received in letters about this were from
people who can't sleep at night
i've had nightmares about climate crisis
and having taking action is the best
antidote to despair and apathy and i
think the government has a role here we
have the funding to do it that we're in
an unusual situation with funding and
this could be something the commission
doesn't have to last forever but it's
four meetings a year
but you know for a couple of years i
think it's a it's a worthwhile endeavor
and could have very positive
ramifications for bringing young people
to the state for retaining people who we
are losing because people don't see
opportunities here
thank you we might retain more of our
young people if we
built more affordable housing here in
new hampshire
so do i
i was supposed to testify on it this
morning but municipal and county
government was so far behind i never got
to it so
now i have to come back wednesday i
might also point out that the
climate
civilian climate corps that's mentioned
in this bill
was originally envisioned as being part
of the buildback better plan which has
now apparently died in congress
so
there may not be a
a
federal or nationwide civilian climate
corps in the near future
therefore i would think it would be
premature to start a commission to
advise such a climate corps if it
doesn't exist
all right seeing no further comments on
this issue i think i would like to ask
the clerk to call the role on the motion
to itl house bill
1419 mr clerk
thank you representative thomas
recommendation to itl yes
uh representative johnson
yes
representative daughter yes
representative berner
yes
the clerk votes yes
representative bernardi
yes
representative campbell's
representative
yes representative white
yes representative lewicki
yes
representative samsic
no representative callie pitts
representative man no representative
oxram
no
representative vincent is not here or
represent mcgee
representative mcwilliams
no representative creature no
representative pimentel no
representative partial
no
and the chair
yes
13 yes
okay
one two oh
three four five six seven eight nine ten
eleven
twelve
yeah correct twelve yes
one two three four five
one
you're correct both cases
okay by a vote of 12 to 9 the motion to
itl hb
1419 passes
so i will close the public hearing on
the executive session rather on hb1419
and i will open up
an executive session on hb 1506 and
recognize representative lewicky for a
motion thank you mr chairman i recommend
itl on hb1506
and the chair recognizes representative
merner thank you mr chairman i would
second the motion to itl
it's been moved and seconded that we
mr ital hb 1506
is there discussion
minority reports and majority reports
for the last bill
good question and good point thank you
yes we will uh
assign a majority um
a minority reporting writer perfect
representative kelly pitts
representative callie pitts will write
the minority report
okay
okay so now we have a motion on the
floor to itl hb 1506
is there discussion on the motion
representative mick williams
thank you chair bose uh as you know uh
this was a bill that i prime sponsored
um
to focus on
creating a fund that could be revolving
to focus on new and uh
nascent energy projects in the state of
new hampshire
um i'd love to have some more discussion
on it i i did present an amendment uh i
don't know if everyone's had an
opportunity to look at it but they've
been handed out and if you don't have
one let me know i have a stack over here
of extra
1506 amendments basically it takes the
base bill and just amends a couple of
the sections that we discussed during
testimony that could be a problem to
iron out some of the issues
including addressing um
vulnerable and low-income communities uh
putting in some enabling language so the
department of energy would actually have
the ability to farm out through the
request for proposals process management
for banks um
to manage the funds rather than the
department of energy managing funds
and also making sure that this
can actually sustain with financing fees
over the long term
but for the for for the short term the
intention was that
these funds would be used to pay for
staff at the department of energy at
least until things get going so more
enabling language there
but
as we discussed at the public hearing
really the intent here is for this bill
to be a bucket
to create a bucket of funds so that we
can look to the future of energy in the
state of new hampshire and so i'm
disappointed to see an itl
recommendation right out the gate and
i'd like to understand a little bit more
about other concerns with this concept
i'm happy to have a discussion about
that
okay
would anyone like to uh
representative lewicky has a comment
thank you mr chairman
hb 1506 would duplicate many programs
that are already in existence both
public and private
these existing programs in both include
both government and commercial
the if by it would make the gov
government of new hampshire the investor
of last resort after everybody else has
refused these programs
the it would impose mandates and costs
on the department of energy which are
not addressed
and
which the department of energy
apparently does not wish to undertake
and the final one which may have been
taken out in the amendment which i
haven't seen would be the explicit
racial discrimination on page 3 lines 10
through 12. that was removed would you
like a copy of the amendment sure
okay further discussion on uh house bill
1506 and the motion to itl
representative samsich
thank you mr chairman um
this bill
is something that as the fiscal note
mentions is often referred to in other
states as setting up a green bank
and it's been done in many places and
the idea is we we can have a revolving
fund
to
help fund various projects that have to
do with energy efficiency or
energy projects and so forth
and it would be self-sustaining
essentially when it's a revolving fund
you you basically give out the loan and
you get the money back
and it would be funded by various
sources federal state and organizations
all over the country who are currently
actually putting money into such funds
to encourage
more
projects of this nature
including many corporations that are
doing it because they want to make a
statement about their particular company
so i think this is this is a worthwhile
effort and uh
if
i i don't think there's much of an
effort going on right now in our state
to do this
but uh
we we have to start somewhere and we
have to start by having a fiscally
responsible way of funding projects like
this
it's always surprising how many people
in other states once you have a fund
like this how many organizations
companies and others step forward to say
i'd like to put some money into that i
think that's a good investment for my
future and my children's future
thank you
thank you further discussion on house
bill 1506
representative mcgee is recognized for a
comment thank you mr chairman yeah i
think i'd like to just reiterate i i'm
always happy when i see folks come up
with you know creative ideas that have
worked in other places for us to
consider
and
i actually really like this bill because
i think uh the concept of the bucket
uh is to say that if we don't have a
bucket no one's going to be putting
anything in the bucket but if we
if we enable
uh a place for green funds to be
collected
then it it could end up being a force
multiplier in a very positive way for
finding supports for things that we
don't want to fund through other means
so if we don't want to fund things
through rate payers
and we have exceptions to those types of
programs and then we look at
this which is offering us an alternative
which is saying
we're going to allow people who have
funds and have interest in this to be
able to donate their money here and let
us put it to work for them
i think it's a really worthwhile idea
and i just i want to thank you for
bringing it
i have heard of green banks before but i
know new hampshire hasn't done anything
like this before so i
i just commend you for bringing it and i
i hope that folks will consider it more
strongly than to just say we've decided
it's going to be inexpedient to
legislate because this is this is the
kind of idea that we should probably be
coming together across party lines to
support
it doesn't cost anybody anything
and it gets us where we would like to be
which is having money available for
people to do things that will benefit
everybody
thank you representative bernard is
recognized for a comment
thank you mr chairman
so this idea to me is perfect as a
private nonprofit enterprise not as a
government-run organization
and i commend you to things like tunnel
for towers or habitat for humanity these
are organizations that
have a slightly different tilt than what
you're looking at but the concept is
there and it demonstrates that private
non-profits can clearly do
the kind of thing that you're looking to
accomplish
further discussion representative mick
williams do you have another comment you
wanted to make
i i just wanted to reiterate that there
is no state funds at all in this bill
this is
completely
volunteer donations
and if available federal funds this is
not a state funded this is not about our
taxpayers or even ratepayer dollars
thank you now that you mentioned that i
would point out that the fiscal note
with this bill suggested that a source
of funding for this green bank could be
american rescue plan funds but i would
remind everyone that those are one-time
funds
and even if there were some allocated to
this green bank
it would need to get other
money from somewhere else at
in the future in order to sustain itself
representative oxenom
thank you mr chair
yes
the one-time funds are helpful to set up
the fund so it's not looking for ongoing
funds although who knows what the feds
may come up with in the future if you
look at the top of page four
it says outright that this is looking to
partner with private capital providers
and capital markets to attract
co-investment from private banks
community development financial
institutions investors and others in
order to drive new investment into under
penetrated markets to increase the
efficiency of private capital markets
with respect to investing in greenhouse
gas production projects and to increase
total investment from the fund and then
it specifies underneath of that this is
not something a private organization
like habitat for humanity is capable of
doing you know this is something that
needs to be audited it needs to be
financially secure it needs to be
vetted by
the banks and also by the federal
funders so yes i think the you know the
idea here is is a good one and it is
certainly not duplicative of anything
that is currently going on in new
hampshire
and it would bring funding to
under-resourced areas that currently do
not receive funding because there's not
the security for the capital
private investment to
reference representative bernardi's
point
it's perfectly possible for private
investors to do this at this at this
moment but they don't have the security
to do it this would be a secure
mechanism
and i think it's it's uh we should
support it thank you
thank you representative callie pitts
you had a question a comment to make did
you not
i did and i guess i i felt that
this type of funding for a long time i
thought would be
excellent for this revolving fund for
low income housing or medium income
housing which you
mentioned
i also believe that this bill
probably
is not
ready for prime time and i hate to say
that but i i don't think it is
and i think it deserves more attention
and more study either in this committee
or in another committee and i know and
because i say things like a loose cannon
it's election year and it's hard
to get people to want to study things
but i think the time has come
arpa money is available we need seed
money is what we used to call it in the
old days we need seed money it's like
priming the well you got to put water in
it sometimes to get it out
so i think that this is
is not quite ready
to become an rsa
but i think it's not quite ready
to die
thank you
uh any further comments
i'd remind all members that
there were similar programs that have
been created in the past the first one
that comes to mind is the pace program
that
attempted to do very similar things as
this bill
and that program has
been wrought with
fraud
with
manipulation
with financial
problems and has not delivered on its
promises
and as a result of that i would be
reluctant to go forward with the program
such as this one without a more robust
description of how it would
operate how it would be overseen and how
it would be funded
representative callie pitts did you have
a response to that the response i had
was simply that this
this to me is one of the reasons that it
needs
a program like this one needs more study
but needs more state controls than what
we can have than what we can put on it
that we can audit that we can that we
can make sure the money goes where it's
supposed to
and
if it was a private totally private
thing we wouldn't have that control so i
think that that's just proves
to me the proof is in the pudding that
that we would need
to have it as a state control program
representative
thompson you have another comment thank
you mr chairman just a quick one it
seems to me under the circumstances
right now where we're trying to define
what exactly the department of energy is
supposed to do or not do
this is the kind of program it should be
doing in all kinds of areas so
um it seems to me that's worth keeping
in mind that just because we don't have
it now doesn't mean we won't have
anything like this in the future
okay thank you for that comment
seeing no other for further comments on
this bill i'd like the
clerk to call the role on the motion of
itl on house bill 1506 mr clerk
representative thomas
representative johnson yes
representative nadar yes representative
mirner
yes representative plett yes says yes
representative berezni
yes representative bernardi yes
representative campbell's
yes representative pleasure yes
representative white
yes representative lewicki yes
representative samsich
no
representative callie pitts
representative mann
representative occidental no
representative vincent not being here
representative mcgee
representative mcwilliams
emphatic no
representative creature also emphatic no
representative penintel
representative partial no i have twelve
nine one you didn't ask that uh
vote chairman votes
yes
you want to take the job over you can
committee will be in order please mr
clerk please announce the result of the
vote i just did 1291 after i asked for
your
vote
okay
by a vote of 12 yays and nine nays
the motion to itl house bill 1506
is adopted
will there be a minority report
yes i believe representing mick williams
you're right there minority thank you
representative mcwilliams will write the
minority report
and incidentally mr chairman when will
you need these reports
i was just about to mention that we need
those reports
by
close of business tomorrow
i have to submit them on wednesday
morning
okay with that we'll close the public
hearing on hb 1506
and we will open a public uh
why do i keep saying public hearings we
will open an exec session on hb 1601
relative to funding the new hampshire
saves program and the chair recognizes
representative white for a motion
thank you chairman i'd like to move that
we itl this
representative white has moved itl on hb
1601 representative bernardi is
recognized
thank you mr chairman i second that
motion it's been moved and seconded that
we itl hb 1601
is there any discussion
um mr chairman can i have an amendment
can i give that out to everyone
there is a motion on the floor you can
pass it out for information but there is
a motion on the floor is there any
discretion
of the motion on the floor
okay seeing seeing no uh indication that
there's uh
any discussion to be had well yes
representative samsung is recognized for
a comment
thank you thank you very much mr
chairman um
uh as i mentioned in my testimony on
this bill
this is an attempt to try to ensure that
the
revenues from
the reggie allowances that the state
gets
be at least at a certain floor level and
never go down
uh we had a uh testimony by uh puc
chairman chairwoman dianne martin
telling us uh recently that
the reggie allowance prices are expected
to rise
and as they rise
it would be nice if we could benefit
from that both in the portion that is
invested in energy efficiency which was
the goal of reggie
as well as money that goes back to uh
as rebates to the customers so when the
reggie allowances go back go up
everybody would benefit however if we
don't change the the formula that we
have right now which is just one dollar
of the allowance no matter what the
price of the allowance
then what will happen is as the
allowances rise
the same amount of money would go back
to energy efficiency they would not
benefit from increasing allowance prices
and that was the intention setting a
floor
and saying
if that floor is
is higher then it would be 15
of the allowances instead of just the
one dollar if it's
not it stays at least at a floor level
so this this provides some consistent
funding
uh and otherwise uh we will be losing
out to more investments that we could
make in energy efficiency
thank you
thank you further comments on
house bill 1601 and the motion for itl
seeing none i'd ask the clerk to call
the role on the motion of itl on house
bill 1601 representative thomas
yes
represent uh
hold on
yes i know
representative johnson
yes
why isn't that capitalism hold on
there uh representative notter yes
representative berner yes representative
plett says yes rep representative
berezni yes representative bernardi yes
representative cambrils
yes representative pleasure yes
representative white
yes representative wiki yes
representative samsic no representative
callie pitts
representative mann no
representative oxendium no
representative vincent is not here
uh uh representative mcgee
representative mick williams no
represent creature no representative
pimentel
partial
and the chair yes
that's 1381
by a vote of 13 to 8 the motion to itl
is adopted
does somebody just disagree with the
count
okay will there be a minority report
representative samsich will write the
minority report
okay thank you i will close the
executive session on house bill 1601
forgive me who's doing the minority
report representative samsit thank you
and i will open a executive session on
house bill
1621 and i recognize representative
berezni
thank you mr chairman i motioned that we
itl
hb 1621 fm and i can speak to my motion
okay
first i'll recognize representative
plett i second the motion to itl it has
been moved and seconded
that we itl hb 1621
representative brezhner is recognized to
speak to his motion
thank you mr chairman during the
introductory testimony we heard about
the bill sponsors hometown spending 50
000 to upgrade the library's energy
efficiency
and perhaps plans to do the same for
their school we also heard testimony
about the ease of installing blown in
installation
all of those things happen under current
law and funding levels i did not hear
testimony on why the current funding
amount is inadequate or how much would
be adequate to achieve the implied
energy efficiency goals
this bill also does not improve the
energy efficiency aspects brought up by
the bill
there were two things one is uh the
funding for municipal projects would not
increase because that amount is capped
two million by rsa 125
0-colon 23
2b this bill does not increase that cap
and then two it changes the
administration of the energy efficiency
programs from electric distribution
companies to be department of energy and
department of education if the laudable
goals of these programs is blown in
insulation it's not clear how the
department of energy or education will
do a better job of administering this
program
furthermore the department of education
in their fiscal note stated they do not
need additional funds to implement this
program presumably they could therefore
implement it today with with this
without this extra funding
finally my constituents tell me that
they want lower electric bills and this
legislation does the exact opposite
therefore the primary reason for my tl
motion is that
we should not be artificially raising
electric rates thank you
thank you representative berezni further
comments representative mann has a
comment
yes thank you mr chairman um first of
all the um
the cost of so-called cost per for a
rate payer per month
for the um
for this bill
would be
about a dollar a month
uh one utility had showed me 65 cents a
month
it's just not a lot of money
a dollar a month can easily be
wiped off the map by buying a led bulb
and if you really want to save more
money you can wait the six weeks or five
weeks until the led bulb
has paid for itself in savings and
electricity
and you can buy another one
and then you can buy a third one
and so on until you run out of sockets
so the idea that this
reggie rebate that's what i'm calling it
is a complete waste it's throwing money
away that could be used for energy
efficiency it has no beneficial effect
for homeowners it is a complete waste
it is in fact the result of a compromise
made years ago
when there was a bill
promoted by americans for prosperity
new hampshire state director
corey lewandowski
argued for
the
elimination of reggie's support from new
hampshire new hampshire and other states
had joined in this regional greenhouse
gas initiative
he apparently not only
offended the priorities of new hampshire
citizens but also perhaps
offended
the senators with whom he was debating
the future of of the regional greenhouse
gas initiative
at least anyway the reputation is that
he was making threats and the senators
were very angry
i showed up i
this is history that i've researched
i showed up at the scene
before i was a rep
going to a house hearing on
the bill
to get rid of reggie
and there was a man sitting in the front
row
and i was sitting with lots of other
people in the back
and after all this a whole lot of
testimony the chairman
garrity
said to the man sitting in the front row
who was
corey lewandowski
we'll never be able to pass this bill
we'll go with a
rebate so
all of us
non-members of the legislature were
astonished because we had no idea that
it was legal
to change a bill in midstream
from uh what it was originally to be and
turn it into a rebate process of some
kind so it was very difficult to figure
out what what this was all about
and the chairman then recessed the uh
hearing the house hearing for uh several
hours which
succeeded in getting rid of most of the
people who are upset about this bill
anyway
um
but then the senate hearing came along
and
it turns out um
at the senate hearing this where the
reggie rebate the the compromise idea
came so that apparently this rebate was
a compromise made between lewandowski
and the chairman of the
senate and house
committees responsible for energy policy
and the compromise was we would stay in
reggie instead of leaving
but we would
give away all but a dollar of each
allowance
uh this allowance being a unit of
payment from the reggie project
all except a dollar for each allowance
give it away back to
residents for electric bills as rebates
and again that rebate was worth about a
dollar a month now
at the senate hearing the um it appeared
that the lewandowski had been tricked
because he was absolutely frantic in mr
chairman
uh please suspend uh representatives
what is your point of order well i don't
know what this has to do with anything
and um i take exception to hearing
disparaging marks about against somebody
who isn't here to defend themselves
i'm just reporting well taken uh
representative mann if you could give us
your history lesson without making any
disparaging remarks about persons so
we're not here
at any rate the um
the so-called reggie rebate stayed in
other words it was stayed in effect so
the
dissipation i what basically this does
this did
was to take most of the funding that
reggie was raising
and
threw it away uh if you if you can call
it that a dollar a month really isn't
enough to make a difference in a
in a household and again uh a single led
bulb
pretty much wipes out that problem
anyway
so uh there really is no need for this
reggie rebate anymore and i put several
bills in
that were reliably vetoed
to get rid of that rebate
this
bill
is
just the
next attempt to
eliminate the rebate but instead of
doing it all in one shot
it does it gradually over several years
by
2028 i think
so that's basically the essence of the
bill
my argument is
we should not be dissipating money that
is available to do energy efficiency
which is very valuable to families
very valuable
for no good reason
just because of a historical compromise
between
americans for prosperity agent who by
the way
we never saw again
and the people of new hampshire
so
this
this is something to
getting rid of this rebate is something
that's very important to do
uh the bill does it in a gradual way
over seven or eight years
and will be painless
if it is again if it is painless for
anyone
i will be very happy to give him the
gift of a led bellman tell him how to
parlay that in
to replacing all of his bulbs with led
bulbs without spending a penny of his
own money thank you
thank you for your
generous offer to
help us buy
led
bulbs i would remind you that um
the argument that this
is merely a drop in the bucket
is an argument that's made frequently
but today
we spend four percent
of every electricity bill
every ratepayer electricity bill on
energy efficiency
and another three percent for the
renewable portfolio standard for a
combined total of seven percent
when you add to that
the net metering charges
that go go along with that program
and charges from reggie
you're closing in on 10
of an electricity
rate payer's electricity bill
being for
these programs
it's no longer a drop it up in the
bucket when it becomes 10 of a rate
payer's bill
is there any further discussion on this
bill
representative oxenom
thank you mr chair
if you look at the fiscal note the very
last paragraph
the departments indicate the decrease of
ratepayer rebates will result in some
near-term increase in electricity costs
for state county and local governments
however
over the long term increased investment
in energy efficiency projects would save
ratepayers money
the cost savings for state county and
local governments which also would
accrue that's a parenthesis addition
those cost savings are indeterminable
the way this pro energy efficiency
projects work they are guaranteed to
benefit positive cost benefit ratio at a
minimum two to one often four to one
this is money that makes money it's an
investment that is guaranteed that is
audited and that produces savings for
everyone for everyone when we do things
more efficiently what we're cutting is
waste
that's what we're losing here
these monies are needed the the other
reggie states around us have
demonstrated over 10 years you look at
the figures which
mike fitzgerald here from des has
provided us with year in and year out
the numbers demonstrate this is a
positive payoff for the rate payers
short term
yes there is an increase in the bill of
pennies but put together this is
hundreds of millions of dollars this is
people in mobile homes who are
having fires because of their
inefficient heating systems being able
to have livable lives of students being
able to study and and perform their
homework without their fingers being
cold this is about getting a new
refrigerator that runs at 10 the cost of
an old refrigerator
energy efficiency isn't just blowing in
insulation it it's across the board it's
a demonstrated proven winner and we only
hurt ourselves and rate payers when we
cut off the investment funds
thank you
thank you further comments on our
discussion on this bill representative
callie pitts
i'm going to look at some of the reps
and i want to look at them in the eye
having sat here and threw all these
attacks on reggie over the years
and having us wanted to pull out of it
and
this and that and the other thing
i would like to know
one i appreciated the history lesson and
the refreshing my memory because i sat
through those discussions
and i also know
that
some people on this committee were great
proponents
of the rebreak of the
rebate program
and they were not from my party
i would like to know from somebody if
anybody can tell me
what's the average rebate
for a customer an average customer will
be based on a certain amount of kilowatt
hours
is per month
and what is the savings as people now go
and look at the price of fuel when i
look at the price of home fuel i
i see it on my way home there's a
advertisement oh my gosh
how can anybody you know how do you go
and say uh
give me 200 gallons of fuel
and how do we compensate for that
we take it out of the state treasury
because we have
funds
that compensate low income people
for fuel
so if we could save some of that money
that we're taking out of state funds
to compensate people for fuel
perhaps we would look differently
at what this reggie savings program does
and quantify the cost benefit
analysis that we talk so much about
against what the average rebate
per month to a customer is
i would dare to say
they are not even buying a cup of coffee
with it
and we're taking out of one hand and
giving it out with the other
i think that the medium income person
is the one that's suffering
because we do hand out energy efficiency
funds
maybe we could spread that a little bit
more
our fuel assistance funds if we could
spread that out a little bit more if we
had
more fuel efficient
homes
that's my
my statement and my question
to anyone
what is the average rebate based on the
kilowatt hours that we use to do all
these figurings
is it under a dollar
representative plett is recognized for
comment yes thank you what i don't
understand is why it makes sense to
charge an electric rate payer a tax
which is reggie is
and then apply it to an oil furnace i
mean heating
insulation which helps oil furnaces
helps
kerosene furnaces and propane why not
charge that tax on oil not electricity
uh further comments on this question
representative oxenoum
the the short answer is that as we move
to a clean energy future we're using
clean electricity to produce heat not
using like what's now called beneficial
electrification so that we're
it's at the moment
because so many people still
are you know addicted to fossil fuels
yes most of those rebates are going to
homes that are heated by fossil fuels
but the
the end goal here and in the
intermediate goal is to be moving to
much more efficient heat pumps and and
no longer subsidizing uh you know this
whole program of fuel assistance just
keeps people on fossil fuels we need to
be moving off of that and to do that we
need to be investing money in more
efficient ways of heating homes
building homes in ways that they don't
require as much
it's a circular system and if you can
start breaking out of the system and get
into the virtuous circle you're changing
the energy system you're changing the
electricity and so that this program
which you may think at the moment is
taking money from fuel oils to
electricity would be an electricity to
electricity program
thank you
this discussion about throwing more
money
after uh
energy efficiency programs reminds me of
a story that i was going to tell
but on second thought maybe i won't
come up to me after the meeting and i'll
tell you the story
representative bernardi is recognized
for a question or a comment
thank you mr chairman you know the uh
the issue here of of how much this uh
rebate is and what it what what's it
what needs to be done with it
you know is very interesting but my
constituents
are outraged at the cost of their
electricity bill right now and they look
at that bill and they say what's this
charge what's this charge why am i
getting this what's happening here and
anytime that happens
we need to be sensitive to that i am
very sensitive that these charges do not
need to be increased when our electric
bill is going up
uh representative mcgee is recognized
for a comment thank you mr chairman i
think the thing that is interesting
about the regional greenhouse gas
initiative is that is that the
the accounting is done based on
carbon emitters right so it's basically
a carbon tax it's not it's not part of
the electric bill
the regional greenhouse gas initiative
money is money that's rebated to the
state
based on auctions where they decide how
much the carbon is going to cost and
it's how much carbon is emitted in this
state so the argument about the bill
this isn't about the bill that's not
where it rate payers are not paying the
money that comes to the state the
millions that come to the state
what what representative mann's bill is
trying to do is take the money that we
already receive from the regional
greenhouse gas initiative
funding
and
instead of giving it back to everybody
evenly so that
they don't
they don't even know that it's there but
we don't have it to use for anything to
use it for what it was intended for
which is to get us ahead on trying to
convert to a cleaner system
so it's
it's money that was intended
specifically to help us fund something
that wouldn't have to come out of
people's pockets and what we're arguing
is we want to put pennies back in those
pockets rather than use it collectively
to lower our demand for everybody and
lower costs for everybody and so we
don't get the benefit of that cost
multiplier that's what we're being given
we're being given a chunk of money
and
and we're frittering it away instead of
letting it work for us so
that's the difference between how we
view reggie in the state or how we've
been viewing it
and how other states are using it so i
just wanted to
make you know make people understand
that
you're giving pennies back to people but
you're not taking money away from them
by using that money because that money
is coming to the state for the state's
use so the state could put that into
energy efficiency and benefit everybody
and i just think we don't always
understand how
how it operates
of course every ratepayer does pay the
cost for that because it's bundled into
the price of the electricity
that
they receive
when they buy electricity
representative mann your microphone
seems to be on all the time can you turn
it off
you can okay just just uh checking on
again as well did you have one more
comment you wanted to make
okay go ahead
first of all
if you heat with oil
you're going to be using electricity
you've got to drive the oil into the
furnace you've got to distribute the
heat either whether it's an air hot air
system or a hot water system
so you use electricity
you will save
if the effect of energy efficiency on
your electric bill will be a lower the
electric bill
plain and simple
um
and i cannot swallow this idea
that all this money was being is being
created by our membership in reggie we
are seriously trying to reduce
co2 pollution
and all this
money is made available and we choose as
a state as a state government
responsible for what we do
we choose to thr
i accidentally turned off your mic
it's absolutely enraging
i just go back to the point i'll go back
to my earlier point
every heating system requires
electricity and you'll save plenty of
electricity
with this
money that is now being thrown away
thank you
okay thank you we're going around in
circles here we don't seem to be getting
anywhere
uh so i think i would like to ask the
clerk to call the role
all right representative samsich
thank you very much mr chairman
i'd like to
underscore the fact that first of all
insulation
helps everything
even mobile home parks have air
conditioning that runs on electricity
and an insulated mobile home is a better
one than an uninsulated
the funding that is used
in various ways from from this kind of
program includes the funding for uh
low-income energy efficiency measures
and only several years ago we were told
that the backlog the waiting list for
that was almost 10 years
so this idea that we have plenty of
funds uh and and we don't need more
it's just a mythology
we've never been able to service all the
people who have asked that funding now
what does that do for the individuals
who get the
energy efficiency measures it helps
their particular
site reduce energy use but it benefits
everybody when we reduce demand we
reduce transmission costs the number one
factor over the last 10 years increasing
on our electricity bill is not the price
of energy it was the price of
transmission costs that went up higher
in our state than in the neighboring
states for the very reason because we
were not doing much about reducing our
demand
transmission
reduction helps everyone
business activity that's connected to uh
all the efforts for energy efficiency
measures
for both insulation as well as for
projects
that we need
they generate business activity jobs
something in our economy and they reduce
the amount of fossil fuels we need to
import from out of state and out of the
country
all these things actually impact
everybody even if you don't make use of
these the energy program yourself
indirectly by doing this
they will drive down your costs so
these measures help everybody not just
the person actually making use of them
thank you
thank you representative
during the
negotiations that i conducted with the
senate on house bill 549
which the senate passed last thursday on
its consent calendar
and that bill will be coming back to us
for concurrence
um
next wednesday or thursday whenever
it comes up i'm not sure exactly when
it'll appear
i'll have to talk to the clerk about
that
but during the course of those
negotiations i asked the senate if they
would consider increasing the percentage
of money allocated to low-income
customers from 20 to 30
and the answer i got was no
which surprised me a little bit
but the reasoning behind their answer
was that the utilities have told members
of the senate
that they can't find
people to take those energy efficiency
services
beyond 20 percent
so they didn't think they could they
could find ways to spend that money
i found that
kind of hard to believe but
but i had to accept their word for it
they refused to budge on increasing that
percentage from 20 to 30 percent
so i just point that out any further
discussion i think it's time maybe we
had a vote
representative uh thomas has a
con
thank you mr chair um sorry to extend
this but i just wanted to
comment on the previous
representative
comments involving transmission costs
and energy costs
it should be known that the
cost of your electric bill is the the
energy cost is approximately fifty
percent of your electric bill
the cost of transmission
is approximately eleven percent of your
electric bill while it is true that the
percentage increase of cost of
transmission has increased over the
years higher at a higher rate than the
cost of your energy
it is still
quite a bit lower than the cost of
energy so if you can decrease the cost
of your energy
by a lot you could decrease your your
electric bill that's all i have to say
about that i will be supporting the
the recommendation to itl
representative oxenam
thank you very much for your indulgence
mr chair
the the point about the
increasing electricity costs is not
about
reggie or this
systems benefits charge it's about the
cost of natural gas
worldwide natural gas prices are going
up
tremendously we have to pay that because
we have not invested in alternatives we
have not taken the road of fuel
diversity and to to say that you know we
have to meet our constituents and say
well i'm doing something about the
electricity bill when you're working on
the one percent and the three percent
and the six percent
it's
yes energy is is fifty percent and
that's the big problem we have to change
our energy system and to do that we have
funding through reggie we're throwing
the money away that money needs to be
safeguarded it needs to be stewarded it
needs to be used for the projects that
will pay off for our ratepayers for our
businesses to grow our economy not
sending four to six billion dollars out
of state every year on fossil fuels
investing it in hydro
wind
solar that are here these are our new
hampshire industries please
defeat this bill
representative oxenom is correct about
the price of natural gas
driving the cost of electricity about 70
percent of the time or 70 percent of the
marginal price is set by the price of
gas earlier today the locational
marginal price was over 300 dollars
and right now it's down to about 142
dollars per megawatt hour and that's
largely largely due to the fact that the
temperature has warmed up outside and
we're now using 58 percent
of the gas
available to us to generate electricity
whereas this morning we're only
losing about 40 percent gas because
there wasn't enough gas available
so representative kreshan is recognized
for a comment thank you and i promise
i'll be brief um i'm really glad that
you brought up the bill that just went
through the other body um because i
wanted to remind everyone that just a
month ago we voted unanimously as a
house on the importance of funding new
hampshire saves um i know we've had lots
of conversations in this committee about
whether the system's benefits charge is
the appropriate
mechanism for this reggie to me
seems like it's meant for
for this it's meant for energy
efficiency it's meant for
you know reducing our dependence on
carbon so
um
you know whatever your feelings about
the sbc why not use this bulk of money
to fund um the projects that it's meant
for thank you
okay i hope we've exhausted this topic
and can
move on to a vote we do have another
bill that we have to adjudicate here
this afternoon so
seeing no more hands up i'm going to ask
the clerk to call the role on the motion
of itl on house bill 1621.
representative thomas yes
representative johnson yes
representative notter yes representative
mirner yes
representative plett votes yes
representative berezni yes
representative bernardi
yes representative kimbrells
yes representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
wiki yes representative no
representative callie pitts
representative mann no representative
occidental no
representative vince is not here
uh
representative mcgee
representative mick williams no
uh represent christian no representative
pimentel
representative partial no
the chair yes
i get it is uh
okay by a vote of 12 to 9
the motion to itl house bill 1621
is adopted
and the minority report will be written
by
yes i think white john mann
representative man okay
remember representative that report is
due by end of day five o'clock close of
business tomorrow
tuesday that was my question thank you
even though we're all going to be here
tomorrow so i guess you have to work on
it tonight
okay
all right
so uh mr mr chairman can i just make uh
an informational comment here
representative samsic uh i think uh last
time we met uh at hearings
we there was the talk about whether
reggie had issued its annual report
about the regis reggie program
and i came across a report october 1st
dated to this committee
which is the official
reggie annual report and incidentally
that's also that's a report that went to
the
to the uh oversight committee as well at
the time
okay thank you
so i'll close the public hearing on
house bill 1621
and i will
open a public hearing on house bill
1644.
exec session exec session
okay you need a bio break all right take
a five minute bio break
we'll recess the exact session and be
right back in five minutes
those
okay five minutes are up let's move on i
would like to open the public the
executive session on house bill
and the chair recognizes representative
thomas
thank you mr chair
i want to preface my comments by saying
the subcommittee on 1644 met
and today
we
voted
to recommend interim study on this bill
and um so therefore i am making a motion
to i to interim study 1644 i'll follow
with comments after the second
representative knotter is recognized
it's been moved and seconded that we
report hb 1644
as
moved to interim study and
representative thomas is recognized to
speak to the motion thank you mr chair
because this issue is so complex and
additionally emotionally charged i would
like to read my comments because
i think i've wore them carefully the
committee
was confused but my comments are
that the committee heard testimony that
clearly showed people who lived near
radio frequency emitting towers had
various physical and neurological
medical issues
testimony was also heard explaining the
5g technology which is mainly a
marketing term used to indicate the next
generation of cell phone and data
equipment it's built on 3 and 4g
technology and requires more densely
positioned antennas and expanded
infrastructure
industry leaders in world organizations
have produced numerous documents
pointing to no serious effects in people
from this technology yet it cannot be
denied
certain people are suffering from
various illnesses
although there may be a correlation
between those who live near towers who
suffer from some form of discomfort the
committee was uncertain as to the
causation of such ailments despite the
fact that there was a 14-month
commission that presented a very strong
report that pointed to the effects
of cumulative radio frequency
bombardment there were equal
presentations that pointed to the
physics and testing that could that
could dispel this claim
the committee feels there is enough
doubt
that this bill as presented could not be
supported yet a better compromise could
be obtained with additional study
therefore the committee recommends that
we do interim study to produce perhaps a
better recommendation for the next
biennium
i just have a question uh for
representative thomas you said we met
today we didn't did we yes we did i you
were absent
was it an account it was clear it was
clearly sent out by carrie an official
notice that we're having a subcommittee
today
at 12 30.
well it was it it the the subcommittee
that this afternoon at 12 30 heard two
presenters which also presented during
the public hearing so you didn't miss
anything but we did have the vote then
as well
i
i saw that and then i re-looked at the
calendar
and the re the calendar didn't have it
listed so i
yeah
did it have a 10 o'clock okay thank you
thank you mr chairman i agree with
our vice chair and uh we just had so
much conflicting information it's like
who do you believe and you you can't
kill a bill when there's when there's
doubt and you can't pass it either when
there's doubt and we're watching you
know one person testify someone behind
them shaking their head and then that
person they switch places and then the
one behind them is shaking their head
it's like i think our only option is to
go to
to study just study it some more
thank you chair
uh there's an amendment however we like
to add
to the uh bill we're stripping pretty
much the language about the registry
hoping that would have made it easier to
pass i think all that amendment before
us
i don't know if it even needs to be
acted on if we go to interim study
though
which is something which i think is a
very good idea
but um my concern is the timing
that an interim study would involve
i make a personal choice when i use a
device like this
on giving a green light to the industry
i'm choosing for every citizen in the
state of new hampshire
the hippocratic oath says first do no
harm
i would hope that you could apply that
here
and as i said i support an interim study
but a delay in 5g rollout should have no
effect on current technology 4g
technology and it would provide time to
further examine many of these issues
which i too am very confused about
uh
knowing that these questions on 5g
technologies happening in many states
i'm not too worried about being left
behind
my greater concern is that we're by
doing nothing we'll open the state to 5g
where it's convenient
when we have not even finished the job
of limiting our eliminating our 4g holes
in coverage
or even the broadband fiber coverage
which i'd like to add is working very
well in my area
um
we already have this bill amendment i
said and one of my fellow
representatives here today suggested we
could achieve the reasonable moratorium
and still explore the many concerns
by redrafting an amendment to move up
the enactment date but also place a
reasonable sunset clause on the
legislation perhaps a year
in that time i would hope you're able to
identify and really get a handle on what
we're being asked to legislate and i
would also add that we could also add a
further amendment that could address the
concerns of ham radio operators which i
know we've all received mail to that
effect
so there's many reasons to support and
oppose a bill
i myself am not sure exactly where i
stand in technology but one point that
concerns me
is the legislative overreach that the
fcc is imposing on local zoning
even if i fully support 5g technology
should i do nothing
and um and one by doing nothing give my
tacit approval to that type of overreach
so i would strongly urge just call to
consider the complexities of the debate
and take sufficient time to do what's
best in regards to the citizens of new
hampshire or the minimum as i said
before do no harm thank you
thank you representative partial
representative
that's all right
representative callie pitts
i was just going to reiterate the
original
interim study was mine because i felt
that i did not have enough knowledge
and i still at this point feel that i
still don't have enough knowledge or
enough clarity to vote
to
proceed with this bill but i don't want
it to die
and one of the things i
would
ask the chair
is if we do have an interim study
that means if it passes the study
committee would be
implemented
that is correct in fact i will ask for
volunteers for the study committee
before we leave here this afternoon
and
if i could follow that study committee
will meet
over the course of
could be the summer could be this you
know the rest of this year
to study this issue
correct
thank you
i'm concerned that the discussion seems
to be focused on sort of an all or
nothing either we you know completely
say 5g is uh you know worthwhile and it
should go everywhere
or you know some people are saying you
know we're going to be ending 5g in new
hampshire we're going to fall behind the
rest of the country
this
the commission worked long and hard and
came up with a recommendation which is
limited it's about
restricting
certain kinds of technology in certain
kinds of areas and particularly if we
adopt the amendment which i think would
be a benefit because i think the
registry has all kinds of issues about
it
it would allow us to proceed
fiber optic is being rolled out in many
parts of the state
but there are parts as we heard this
morning particularly wilderness
rescues and also for first responders
where you do need cell coverage
but by moving
forward towards fiber optic and having
cells
fill in the areas that fiber optic it
cannot reach we can we can achieve an
optimal situation so but this bill does
not ask us to prefer any technology over
another
it simply says we have concerns about
this one technology in certain areas
you know we've been told oh but it's low
frequency and they're you know but they
have to be 250 feet apart well you get a
whole bunch of those things
all in the circle and they're all
radiating out and they don't simply
radiate in every direction they go out
in a flat line so you're talking about a
circumference
at head height
this is a technology which our
commission
worked hard
for long hours brought in experts
considered this
this is a recommendation that i think we
do need to give due respect to the work
that was done yes we've had difficulty
wrapping our heads around it i listened
to the sub the original public hearing
on
youtube i sat in on the subcommittee
meetings i've i've listened to this i've
talked to experts outside of this room
it's a difficult difficult issue but
this recommendation is not saying
yes to f5g no to 5g yes to this no it's
saying
let's limit this in areas where
residences
schools
hospitals let's make sure that we don't
have
and
this technology which is on top of all
the other technologies
and
for biological systems we have to think
about cumulative impacts not simply what
what is this one doing but what is this
one doing on top of all of the others so
i would i would suggest that we
seriously consider the amendment and we
move forward with ought to pass
with simply these limited restrictions
that came out of the hard work of that
commission
thank you
thank you further discussion on the
motion representative thomas thank you
mr chair
this bill as written
had no chance of passing through the
house in my opinion
and in talking to
a senator who was co-sponsored on this
bill admitted it
would be a very very
big effort to have it pass in the senate
i believe
that
something should pass
if we went forward with this or the
amendment it likely would not pass the
house but even if it did it would more
likely not pass the senate and we would
be left with nothing
i believe that the interim study is
paves a way forward for us to come up
with better wording
and perhaps a
compromise if you will
of something
that could get a foot in the door to
handle this this perceived problem it
may very well be a problem
and to further examine
a better way to handle this technology
so
interim study in my book
gives us a chance to
improve on this bill and get something
done
thank you mr chairman and uh i i
appreciate the comments uh from
representative thomas and i would just
like to say that um
you know i agree that
that the commission did good work and
that they
tried very hard to put what they felt
was the prescription or the solution
into the bill
but i i think we we've heard enough
testimony from people who have talked
about other considerations that were not
the focus of that commission that have
to be considered
and so from my perspective whether it's
the department of safety's concerns or i
heard someone earlier say some hospitals
would want the antenna to be closed for
the first responder and other types of
things there are considerations that we
have not deliberated on
that would need to be included in the
bill for it to really serve everyone and
i think that's that i would i would go
along with
further study to answer some of those
questions because i think we can't
as with many bills we can't listen to
only one constituency and their concerns
we have to understand when we put
something in place that it actually
works for the people we intend it to
work for and that means we have to talk
to them so
i feel there's still stuff that's open
yeah
oh there we go had to turn it on and off
yeah exactly unplug it and yeah
[Laughter]
um
oh sure okay
but um
i guess what i'm wondering is is that we
really have a it seems to me like
there's choice here refer it directly to
an interim study
or
put it out as a
otp
a and if it needs further amendments so
be it
but
one way would actually
put a moratorium on
the development of 5g until we have a
full handle on it and by referring it
directly to interim study we would not
have that moratorium so i think the
question what it comes down to is
whether or not we feel comfortable
with going ahead with a study when in
the end whatever we whatever the results
of that study may already be nullified
by what the industry's already done
so that's my concern
thank you thank you mr chairman uh
i likewise
support the interim study motion
yes i think so
oh it's okay
i support the interim study motion and
i think this gives us a little
opportunity
after uh
representative ramy did such a thorough
job with this commission and trying to
get a handle on this
but for us as a committee to step back a
little bit
and
consider that there is very powerful
business interests involved here who are
pushing this thing it's part of a
marketing campaign and um
and you know i understand that the
department of safety is connected and so
are emts and others who use this
network for safety purposes
but that's not the real business going
on the business of of of this 5g is
going to be broader to everybody
and before that gets rolled out i think
we need to be cautious and make sure
that the best interests of the residents
of new hampshire are served
and i think expanding broadband which
had huge support from both sides of the
aisle that everyone should get
high-speed broadband
this this issue with 5g seems to divert
our attention from that and i think it
would be very beneficial if we make sure
that that doesn't get sidelined as
part of this process thank you
representative callie pitts
i want to say that um i want to dovetail
a little bit on what representative
samsich said it's high speed
and affordable was what
was left out of that remark
and i do believe and and this was my
concern at the very
get-go we are not going to put a
moratorium on anything
we at this point
i believe do not have the authority
to either say yay or nay you can do it
or you can't
and we don't even have that ability
through the puc because that was given
up so i think
i think that interim study is the best
way to find out how we proceed and
indeed if we can proceed
and
where we go from here and i think that
in the meantime
we need to educate people as to what's
going on
that just that 5g
what it is and how it works thank you
hello okay now it's working
um
any more comments on this
question
representative merner did you have a
comment nope okay
okay seeing none i asked the clerk to
call the role on the motion of interim
study for house bill 1644.
representative yes
representative johnson
yes representative notter yes
representative mirner yes representative
plett votes yes representative berezni
yes representative bernardi yes
representative campbells yes
representative pleasure yes
representative white yes representative
lewicki
yes
representative yes
representative callie pitts
representative mann yes
representative oxford no
representative vincent's
not present
mcgee representative mcgee
representative mcwilliams no
representative creation
no
representative pimentel
yes
representative partial no
uh in the chair yes
to three to one
1741 you're correct
it's hard because it's on two pages on
my sheet okay
by a vote of 17 to 4 the committee will
recommend that house bill 1644
go to interim study i want to thank you
all for
your careful attention to this
complicated subject
all the work you've done do we have a
minority report on that
does anyone want to submit a minority
report i think uh representative
representative partial will submit a
minority report now before we go home i
know everybody's anxious to get out
there and try to beat uh potential snow
or rain but it's too late it's snowing
snowing already okay all right well in
that case why don't we just stay here
for a couple hours
so i'll tell you the story after the
cameras go off but
before we do anything else i would like
to solicit names uh volunteers who would
serve on the subcommittee
that will pursue
the interim study for this bill so
representative lewicki
representative cretian
representative partial
representative notter
representative white
representative cali pitts
representative thomas
representative berezni
anyone else that's one two three four
five six seven eight
um
that'll be a pretty good study committee
so
i'll look forward to putting that
together
no this is the
what we're talking about right now is
the study committee
that will
complete the interim study of this
question
and make a recommendation there are two
recommendations you can make coming out
of interim study
one is this bil this subject is not
recommended for future legislation the
other is this subject is recommended for
future legislation and you can describe
what that future legislation might look
like
so
this committee of eight people
will meet
i will choose one of you to be the chair
probably representative thomas
and
that person will call meetings
at
his or her convenience
in conjunction with in consultation with
the rest of the folks on the committee
and you guys will start meeting it
probably won't happen until
after the close of business on may 26th
but it could happen before that but it
probably won't
representative partial
and that's because i'm the rookie here
this interim study is dependent upon
this uh
uh being approved by the full house
right
yes okay thank you just want to make
sure okay
but with a vote of uh
17 to 4 i suspect it will be so
all right so i'm going to close the
executive session on house bill
and remind everyone that you need to be
back here tomorrow morning at 9 00 9 a.m
for
five public hearings the final five
public hearings that we will uh
conduct
for this
for house bills right for the house
bills for this session year
so we'll see you all at nine o'clock
tomorrow please drive carefully tonight
and tomorrow morning
and thank you everyone for your hard
work
you